[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo le magazine des temps
forts de l'actualité de la semaine à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat avec
un mais côté thibault note bon gentil
bonjour auriol et cette semaine notre
invité est xavier iacovelli bonjour je
vous êtes sénateur socialiste des
hauts-de-seine merci d'être avec nous
cette semaine et dans l'actualité
parlementaire cette semaine il y a
d'abord le début d'une longue route pour
la loi mobilité
le texte qui vise à renforcer et verdir
l'offre de transport dans le pays et à
désenclaver les zones rurales a franchi
une première étape avec son adoption en
commission au sénat
la question du financement de la loi a
été au centre des débats
premier rendez-vous parlementaires aussi
pour la loi santé cette fois ses côtés a
semblé que le texte a entamé son
parcours avec l'audition de la ministre
de la santé agnès buzyn mardi
l'assemblée qui s'est aussi penché sur
les privatisations prévues par la loi
pour la croissance et la transformation
des entreprises
la majorité a rétabli les privatisations
des aéroports de paris et de la
française des jeux
repousser un mois plus tôt par le sénat
enfin une proposition de loi sur
l'interdiction des ailes bd le texte
porté par les communistes au sénat a été
rejetée mais il a été l'occasion de vifs
débats sur ces lanceurs de balles de
défense mis en cause après de graves
blessures infligées à des manifestants
et on commence cette semaine par la loi
mobilité qui débute son parcours
parlementaire par le sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les sénateurs qui ont voté cette loi en
commission mais l'ont largement remanié
car il trouvait le texte décevant
ils ont adopté deux 140 amendements
notamment pour améliorer le volet
financier et donner plus de moyens aux
collectivités territoriales jordan klein
la commission de l'aménagement du
territoire a adopté deux 140 amendements
parfois à l'unanimité sur ce texte les
sénateurs dénoncé les nombreuses lacunes
présente dans la version le gouvernement
notamment sur le volet financier on a
voté différentes dispositions
financières notamment pour que les
intercommunalités qui se voit confier la
compétence de la mobilité et les moyens
de mettre en oeuvre cette compétence est
également pour que les projets en termes
d'infrastructures et d'investissements
soient soient financées et que l'on ne
soit pas dans dans le flou total en
matière de financement en effet les
sénateurs souhaitent que le milliard
d'euros récoltés grâce à la tei cpe
c'est taxes sur les produits
énergétiques soient entièrement consacré
au portefeuille de la mobilité
mais le sénat a aussi ajouté d'autres
points inciter au développement de
nouvelles infrastructures dans les zones
où les offres de mobilité sont rares
favoriser les développements à vélo avec
la création d'un schéma national des
routes pour bicyclettes créer des voies
et des stationnements pour les véhicules
à faibles émissions
la commission a aussi adopté à
l'initiative du sénateur jean sol un
amendement permettant de renforcer la
sécurité des passages à niveaux que vous
avez deux nominations de la signalétique
on se rend compte qu'il ya des feux
aujourd'hui qui sont un maître 25 ou 1 m
il suffirait de les donner donner sur
élevé parce que quand vous vous trouvez
dans son bus ou dans 1 dans un camion il
est très compliqué de les voir venir la
visibilité retourner passage à niveau se
rend compte que parfois des yé d'arbres
qui sont très très autres il suffirait
de les donner de les élaguer les
sénateurs déplore l'absence de nombreux
sujets notamment celui du cas des
petites lignes ferroviaires une volonté
du gouvernement
le texte sera débattu en séance publique
durant la troisième semaine de mars
vous allez à kobe liant la vue le sénat
a modifié ce texte en commission est ce
que le texte
vous allez le soutenir alors pour
l'instant vous savez on en est au tout
début donc en commission effectivement
on a soutenu un certain nombre
d'amendements
et puis on voit dans l'achat de la
sagesse du du sénat on a eu l'unanimité
sur un certain nombre d'amendements
pourquoi parce que à l'origine ce texte
était très intéressant il répondait à
une vraie demande
le ministère des transports avait
excusez-moi avait effectivement
l'ambition de répondre à la crise en
partie des gilet jaune et aussi de
désertification on va dire des petites
lignes ferroviaires dans un certain
nombre de deux territoires et on voit
bien que les arbitrages ministériels ont
fait que bercy a eu le dernier mot et on
est passé de vote 221 article à 44 donc
on voit bien qu'il ya un vrai souci peu
d'ambition sur ce texte
à la base et donc c'est le travail de
législatif et parlementaire qui devra
normalement apporter des modifications
dans le bon sens et moi je suis ravi que
la commission ait pu faire ce travail là
avant le travail en hémicycle par
conséquent à l'heure actuelle ce texte
ne répond pas d'après vous à ces enjeux
de vous dites qu'ils correspondent aussi
au mouvement désiré jaune l'écologie le
désenclavement
aujourd'hui on voit bien c'est à dire
que les propositions du sénat vont dans
le bon sens il faut le prendre le côté
positif mais si ça repasse à l'assemblée
et que l'assemblée détricote ce que le
sénat aura proposé oui effectivement ça
n'ira pas dans le bon sens donc on ne
pourra pas soutenir ce type de texte qui
ne sont pas à la hauteur des enjeux
l'examen de ce texte a été repoussé pour
cause de grand débat il va être examiné
en février
est ce que vous trouvez que le texte qui
vous est présentée il tient suffisamment
compte des enjeux des préoccupations
exprimées par les français pendant ce
grand déjà je viens de vous dire pour le
coup ça ne répond pas pour l'instant aux
enjeux les apports de
commission et les apports que nous
allons avoir dans l'hémicycle au sénat
le 19 mars vont permettre à mon avis
d'améliorer ce texte notamment sur le
volet financement les 1 milliards dt
icpe qui devront est effectivement sur
cette loi de mobilité et qui devront
être sur les infrastructures ça c'est
indispensable
les petites lignes ferroviaires c'est
indispensable aussi en province on voit
bien une vraie problématique
moi je prends toujours l'exemple j'ai
regardé un petit peu prenons l'exemple
de quelqu'un qui habite en province qui
touchent le smic qui est obligé de
prendre sa voiture pour faire 30 km pour
aller à son travail pour tous les jours
ils payent 140 et il fait à peu près 2
plein dans le mois 144 euros 140 euros à
peu près pour pouvoir se transporter
uniquement ans on travaillait pas pour
aller aux loisirs pas pour aller en
vacances juste pour aller à son travail
c'est-à-dire 10% plus de 10% de son
salaire sont consacrés donc on voit bien
que aujourd'hui cette fois n'est pas à
la hauteur des enjeux de nos concitoyens
et surtout dans dans la province alors
il ya la question du financement 1 qui
se posent aussi vous avez commencé
emparé ce plan coûtera environ 500
millions d'euros par an ne sait pas à ce
stade où trouver l'argent où on voit
qu'une loi finalement sans s'en donner
les moyens et vous dire c'est un petit
peu le cas dans beaucoup de vous en ce
moment c'est on essaie de faire des des
réponses à l'émotion aux problématiques
aux enjeux mais en fin de compte mais
pas les financements à côté et donc ça
ne va pas jusqu'au bout et donc on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui cette loi n'est pas
financé n'est pas à la hauteur des
enjeux et on ne sait pas comment on va
les financer
et malgré tout on voit bien aussi que un
des proches collaborateurs ainsi un
proche collaborateur de d'emmanuel
macron l'économiste
qui avait dit justement que nous avons
la possibilité aujourd'hui d'emprunter à
0 7 % d'accord dans une
dans un contexte de croissance à 3%
internationale dont on devrait justement
investir maintenant sur les
infrastructures et ne pas laisser faire
des mesurettes
comme on peut le faire et aujourd'hui
dans cette fois en garde pour finir sur
cette question du financement les
sénateurs ont fermé la porte à une
vignette poils aux as qui nourrit raison
oui je pense que c'est pas on n'en est
pas encore sur cette question là je
pense que on ne peut pas rajouter des
taxes supplémentaires
il faut trouver des financements qui ne
soit pas aujourd'hui supporté par par
les français et je pense que c'est plus
compliqué de joutes et des taxes
supplémentaires
allez on en vient à notre deuxième thème
la loi santé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et c'est la ministre de la santé agnès
buzyn qui a défendu le texte en
commission à l'assemblée ce mardi elle
était accompagné de la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur frédéric vidal
l'une des mesures phares de la loi
portent en effet sur la refonte des
études de médecine avec la suppression
du numerus clausus beaucoup d'autres
mesures notamment concernant l'hôpital
passeront elles par des ordonnances ce
qu'ont regretté les oppositions résumé
signée nathalie du loir réforme des
études de santé révision de la carte
hospitalière mais aussi lancement de la
santé numérique des mesures au centre du
projet de loi d'agnès buses ma santé
2022 propose en fait un changement de
paradigme
ce projet de loi est volontairement
resserrer autour d'un nombre limité de
dispositions pour enclencher des
dynamiques un projet de loi resserrée
qui ne compte que 23 articles et des
points bien précis comme la suppression
du numerus clausus
ce concours qui limite le nombre
d'étudiants admis en deuxième année de
médecine pour la majorité cette mesure
est indispensable
le coup de coeur du texte c'est la
suppression du numerus clausus parce que
j'ai entendu les mots de boucherie les
mots de gâchis combien de milliers de
vocation était brisée sur l'écueil d'un
concours quasiment inaccessible agnès
buzyn veut également revoir la carte
hospitalière et clarifier le statut des
hôpitaux de proximité pour y arriver le
gouvernement compte passer par voie
d'ordonnancé inquiétude pour
l'opposition
la refonte de la carte hospitalière sera
dessiné dans les cabinets du ministère
ne recours aux ordonnances exonère au
passage d'étude d'impact sur le nombre
d'hôpitaux menacé par les
restructurations liées à la mise en
place des hôpitaux de proximité que ce
projet de loi était assez rédigé de
façon précipitée et reste quand même
assez flou compte tenu du nombre de
domaine réglementaire et du nombre
effectivement d'ordonner ce que vous
avez cités ce projet de loi contient
également un volet numérique
mais la ministre de la santé s'est
montrée prudente sur la délivrance des
médicaments sans ordonnance nous sommes
favorables à un rôle renforcé des
pharmaciens dans les parcours de santé
donc plutôt oui sur le pharmacien
correspondant
mais je crois que cette évolution des
rôles en termes de prescription doit
nécessiter encore un peu de travail avec
les différents acteurs
après l'audition de la ministre ce texte
sera examiné la semaine prochaine dans
ce domaine de la santé l'inquiétude des
français des territoires qui remonte un
d'ailleurs dans le grand débat c'est
celle des déserts médicaux est ce que ce
texte va permettre d'y remédier selon
alors effectivement je voulais vous le
dire c'est je vois bien que dans le
grand débat c'est une priorité
moi je moi même je les organiser dans ma
ville à suresnes et on voit bien que
c'est un engouement sur cette question
là parce que y compris dans pas
seulement dans des zones rurales mais y
compris dans des dans des quartiers de
villes de france et de petite couronne
on a des déserts médicaux importants et
donc c'est donc une priorité pour les
français malgré tout je vois que cette
loi est quand même une petite loi très
peu préparée et qui n'attend pas du coup
la fin du grand débat et les
préconisations du gouvernement pour
lancer cette consultation est ce et ce
travail parlementaire 23 articles
cette ordonnance on voit bien qu
apparent une volonté forcément de deux
d'avoir un débat approfondi sur la
question de la loi santé puisque la plus
la plupart des des grands thèmes seront
abordés sur sur ordonnance donc il ya un
vrai problème après moi j'ai envie de
prendre le côté positif de cette loi
puisque je passe dans une opposition
systématique et j'estime qu'elle est
quand même des points positifs le
numerus clausus et est un point
effectivement positif on le demandaient
depuis un certain nombre d'années
pourquoi ne pas l'avoir fait avant c'est
vrai mais je vous pose la question je ne
sais rien je n'étais pas au gouvernement
ni parlementaire avant donc je pense
qu'effectivement c'est une bonne mesure
il fallait le faire
après moi je pense que l' annonce aussi
la création de 500 ou 600 hôpitaux de
proximité
en fin de compte on voit bien que ils
vont des classes et des chu pour faire
cesser ces créations donc on n'est pas
sur des créations réel c'était on est
une sur une modification des des
hôpitaux des chu actuelle est donc on
voit bien qu'il ya un risque sur un
certain nombre de
notamment de maternité on voit que les
vingt dernières années il ya eu on a
divisé par deux le nombre de maternités
et donc il ya un vrai souci sur les
spécificités des hôpitaux et notamment
en province le gouvernement
effectivement va revoir cette carte
hospitalière par ordonnance vous l'avez
dit sur le sur la méthode d'abord est ce
que ça vous pose problème et sur le fond
est ce que vous craignez une
rationalisation de certains services et
finalement moins de services publics
mais c'est le cas la rationalisation de
la santé on voit bien que c'est depuis
quelques années déjà
ça c'était atténuer un peu saoul marisol
touraine mais globalement on voit bien
qu'il ya une rationalisation de la santé
des hôpitaux parce que la santé coûte
cher mais aujourd'hui c'est aussi le
modèle français qui est en jeu et aussi
des questions de sécurité qui sont mises
en avant
oui elle qui le dit pas assez d'actes
est elle moins sûr parce que si déjà
l'état payé ce qu'il devait aux hôpitaux
et rembourser les dettes que l'état
avait au niveau des hôpitaux
il y aurait un peu plus de moyens pour
la santé et moi je le voit notamment
dans les hôpitaux de mon département
donc donc effectivement je pense qu'il
ya une volonté de rationaliser et à une
volonté de ne pas passer par par le
parlement pour décider cette carte
hospitalière qui est un vrai problème
parce qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien que
c'est aussi les parlementaires qui ont
cette expérience de terrain
je pense notamment au sénat qui ont qui
sont tous des anciens maires des anciens
conseillers départementaux des anciens
présidents du conseil départemental et
donc on a on voit bien que il ya besoin
d'avoir cette expérience de terrain pour
revoir la carte justement on se souvient
que les présidents d'associations d'élus
ont publié une tribune dans le journal
du dimanche il ya quelques semaines pour
dire qu'il y avait eu un manque de
concertation des élus locaux vous êtes
d'accord
ah bah oui enfin manque de concertation
et on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui les la
volonté de mettre des ordonnances cette
ordonnance sur 23 articles
on voit bien que là on ne veut même pas
aller sur le débat parlementaire
c'est-à-dire qu'ils m'aiment pas de
consultation avant mais ya pas de débat
au niveau du parlement
on va en revenir à notre troisième thème
les privatisations qui font leur retour
à l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la mesure la plus contestée de la
loi pacte pour la croissance et la
transformation des entreprises qui
entamait son examen en nouvelle lecture
à l'assemblée nationale cette semaine en
commission les députés de la majorité
ont donc rétabli les mesures de
privatisation d'aéroports de paris est
de la française des jeux et des
privatisations repoussé par le sénat un
mois plus tôt le ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire a donc dû de nouveau les
défendre explication n'a été frémont
supprimé par les sénateurs en première
lecture les articles clés sur la
privatisation du groupe aéroports de
paris sont rétablis par la majorité et
ce malgré la vigueur des oppositions en
est à la recherche d'un équilibre
budgétaire et que cet équilibre
budgétaire se fait au prix de la cession
de bijoux de famille de ben et ministre
de l'agriculture moi j'ai été
agriculteur donc moi quand j'ai une
bonne vache je la vends pas je la garde
tu fais faire des petits évidemment pour
améliorer le patrimoine génétique de mon
troupeau
ben là c'est pareil en réponse aux
craintes de certains élus bruno le maire
n'hésite pas à lui aussi a utilisé la
métaphore animalière
je pense qu'il vaut mieux vendre sa
vache quand elle produit son meilleur
lait et pas lorsque la vache est tarie
il n'est pas de mauvaise politique que
de privatiser quand les cours sont hauts
en est que l'entreprise se porte bien
parce que c'est là que l'entreprise
rapporte le plus au trésor public et
donc aux contribuables
de son côté convaincu de la nécessité de
privatiser le rapporteur général du
texte rappelle les objectifs fixés
certains d'entre vous s'interrogent sur
le fait de savoir si on fait ça pour
désendetter financer un fonds
d'innovation revoir le rôle de l'état
ont fait les trois en même temps
des arguments qui relève selon françois
ruffin du pathétique
le député laisse entendre que les jeux
sont joués d'avancé
si à l'arrivée c'est vinci qui hérite
d'aéroports de paris
c'est vinci dont on à qui on octroie une
indemnisation parce que pendant 70 ans
il y aura la possibilité possibilité de
revendre ses terres et instituts est ce
ça paraîtra comme étant cousu de fil
blanc
bruno le maire a donc tenu à rappeler
qu'un an
belle d'offres sera lancé le ministre
promet également de communiquer aux
parlementaires le détail du cahier des
charges de la vente
vous avez révélé pourquoi vous opposez à
ces privatisations
mais en fait voilà on est sur un
l'enterrement de l'état stratège dans la
compréhension générale
enfin on n'a jamais vendu un monopole
industriel économique qui est qui et et
rémunérateurs aujourd'hui on gagne de
l'argent l'état gagne de l'argent avec
adp avec la française des jeux et on va
vendre ses bijoux de famille pour
financer un fonds d'investissement pour
l'innovation qui va nous rapporter in
fine est exactement ce que les
dividendes nous rapporte sur adp
française des jeux donc il ya une
incompréhension sur cette volonté de de
vendre adp et la française de jeux et
principalement adp d'ailleurs qui est
pour le coup encore plus stratégique
c'est l'entrée sur la capitale ces
entrées sur le territoire
c2 c3 et commença aéroports
internationaux et donc je pense qu'il ya
une vraie un vraie problématique mais
vrai prénom l'indication on l'a vu
notamment avec toulouse ce qu'on avait
vendu aux chinois et qui sont en train
de le revendre enfin voilà on est on est
dans la spéculation ensuite sur nous nos
aéroports qui pose un vrai problème mais
le ministre l'a redit il ya des
garanties qui sont apportées par le
texte notamment par rapport à la
privatisation des autoroutes qui a
marqué les esprits l'état gardera la
main sur les tarifs
vous n'êtes pas rassuré malgré tout non
moi je suis pas rassurée je pars rassuré
parce que aujourd'hui le ministre pour
justifier cela dit on ne sait pas si ça
ne va pas si la vache bleue veut pas
avoir un les taris dans les années à
venir
mais sauf qu'on sait très bien que d'ici
2030 il ya une expansion on attend 120
millions de passagers supplémentaires
donc on à qui ces aéroports vont devenir
le premier les premiers aéroports
européens donc pourquoi est-ce qu'on se
sépare d'une manne financière importante
de la poule aux oeufs d'or pour pour les
recettes de l'état
je pense que c'est une vraie
faute alors est-ce qu'il ya d'après vous
des intérêts privés à l'heure à l'oeuvre
derrière ces privatisations comme le
soupçonne on l'a entendu le député
fromage de faim je veux pas rentrer là
dedans c'est pas mon rôle je ne suis ni
juge ni l'enquêteur moi je vois les
faits je ne comprends pas aujourd'hui et
les arguments du ministre ne me convainc
pas et ne après après free ne convainc
pas y compris l'ensemble des partis
représentés au sénat
c'est à dire qu'on a eu quand même une
large majorité voire je crois unanime
unanimité sur la question des
privatisations
ce qui est assez cocasse quand on voit
que la droite votent contre des
privatisations enfin donc on voit bien
qu'il ya du droit gauche quand même
importante parce que on voit bien que
c'est un outil stratégique pour la
france et c'est un monopole
rémunérateurs pour l'état et donc moi
aujourd'hui le ministre ne me convient
pas alors sept départements d'île de
france disent réfléchir à prendre des
parts au capital en cas de privatisation
est ce que vous y être favorables alors
on a eu une longue discussion au sein de
mon groupe sur des amendements
permettant justement une fine et on n'a
pas voulu rentrer dedans parce que ça
voudrait dire qu'on était d'accord avec
cette privatisation
aujourd'hui on est sur un combat contre
cette privatisation après que les
collectivités participent
ça restera dans le giron public donc moi
je n'y suis pas opposé mais j'suis pas
sûr que ce soit vraiment le sujet
actuellement et et moi je voudrais avoir
des garanties plus importantes de de
l'état sur ces questions là et
franchement quand on voit que sept
départements d'île de france veulent
effectivement participer au capital en
tout cas m l'hypothèse de participer au
capital et que la plupart d'entre eux
hormis le mien qui a fait de l'excédent
budgétaire la plupart d'entre eux ils
ont du mal à fixer les budgets je pense
que restons sur nos compétences propres
au niveau du des départements plutôt que
d'investir dans un outil stratégique qui
doit être de la responsabilité de l'état
avant tout la privatisation de la
française des jeux a aussi été introduit
dans le texte là encore les garanties
vous semblent insuffisantes quels sont
les risques d'après vous au-delà des
risques moi je ne comprends pas encore
une fois sur cette question d'une d'une
entreprise qui rapporte à l'état qui
rapporte des dividendes importants à
l'état je ne comprends pas pourquoi on
la vend voilà c'est moi ma question elle
est simple l est pas il n'y a pas
forcément un risque particulier autant
sur adp il ya des risques aussi sur
ensuite les relations avec air france
qui sont on sait très bien que adp et
air france étant d avec des actions de
l'état on voit bien qu'il ya des
relations privilégiées aujourd'hui si
demain c'est les qatari qui achètent par
exemple adp que va être la position de
quelle va être la position d'air france
par rapport aux compagnie qatarie donc
moi il ya un vrai souci sur sur même la
stratégie globale sur sur les
entreprises publiques sur la française
des jeux c'est vraiment une question
financière aussi après c'est aussi toute
la question de l'addiction aux jeux
je pense qu'il ya aussi le rôle de
l'état de réguler 7,7
cette entreprise publique sur les jeux
on en vient notre dernier thème le sénat
examine à une proposition de loi sur
l'interdiction des lanceurs de balles de
défense
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les violences lors des manifestations
des gilets jaunes ont mis sur le devant
de la scène la question de ces lanceurs
de balles de défense les flash-ball
utilisées par les forces de l'ordre à
l'initiative des sénateurs communistes
un texte visant à les interdire pour le
maintien de l'ordre était débattu cette
semaine mais la droite sénatoriale s'y
est opposé le texte a donc été rejeté
les explications de jonathan du prise
la position du groupe crc eux est clair
il est urgent d'interdire l'usagé du
lbd40 dans le cadre d'opérations de
maintien de l'ordre
ces sénateurs sont à l'origine d'une
proposition de loi sur le sujet pour eux
cette arme a déjà causé de trop
nombreuses victimes lors des
manifestations de gilets jaunes ont à
111 enquête de l'igpn donc l'esprit de
responsabilité était décidé un moratoire
on regarde les effets de cette arme ses
conséquences les besoins en formation
pour les policiers et voir si une
alternative mais là il faut retirer
outre l'interdiction immédiate de larmes
le texte demande qu'un fichier de police
qui recense notamment les tirs de l bd
soit rendue publique
aussi les sénateurs plaide pour que le
gouvernement révise sa doctrine du
maintien de l'ordre en s'inspirant
d'autres états européens
le résultat serait formalisée dans un
rapport en allemagne c'est la
désescalade
on peut on peut se servir du dialogue on
peut parler avec les gens on peut parler
au lieu de s'approcher des manifestants
il ya des pays qui eux qui dans les
manifestations n'utilise pas des armes
non létales ne sont pas armés et ces
pays ne sont pas moins sûr alors il y a
un problème
examiné par la commission des lois du
sénat ce texte avait été rejeté le 20
février
la commission avait jugé le lb des
nécessaires à un usage proportionné de
la force
les deux ouvert à leur avis et comédie
après s'être abstenue lors de l'examen
du texte en commission en fin février le
groupe socialiste a voté pour le texte
en séance pourquoi alors déjà nous
soutien sans réserve les forces de
l'ordre et on voit bien leur état
d'épuisement depuis de nombreuses années
pas seulement depuis l'acte inde et
gilet jaune qu'il ya eu une escalade de
la violence mais aussi depuis les
attentats où ils sont sollicités
quotidiennement et donc on a un vrai
souci aujourd'hui sur les forces de
l'ordre qu'il faut soutenir qu'il faut
accompagner qu'il faut former et je suis
pas sûr qu'aujourd'hui l'utilisation dlb
des soi même pour eux une solution de
maintien de l'ordre
mais quand même quand vous voyez ces
manifestants de plus en plus violent
tous les samedis à ce que empêcher l
usage de ces lbd pour le maintien de
l'ordre ce n'est pas affaiblir les
forces de l'ordre mais je ne pense
encore une fois qu'il ya des on peut
faire du maintien de l'ordre
on peut protéger nos policiers sans
utiliser délà des armes comme la bd
c'est une arme non létale mais qui et
mutilant gravement
en fait voilà et donc on a aujourd'hui
un vrai un vrai souci des blessés dans
tout l'est dans les manifestations on en
a dans tous les pays c'est ça existe
partout mais des des blessés graves
comme on a actuellement c'est quand même
assez rare en tout cas dans des
démocraties et donc je pense que c'est
pas anodin que l'europe et demandé une
enquête sur l'utilisation de cette bd
c'est pas anodin que le conseil le haut
commissariat aux droits de l'homme de
l'onu a demandé également cette
disposition le défenseur des droits a
condamné aussi donc on voit bien qui
aujourd'hui il ya une mobilisation qui
qui qui se pose la question de
l'utilisation de deux de ses armes et je
pense que on doit stopper l'escaladé de
la violence et c'est à l'état aussi de
prendre ses responsabilités plus
d'effectifs moins d'armes comme les
ailes bd qui aujourd'hui mutile
gravement les manifestants mais qu'un
manifestant qui soit casseurs ou
manifestants pacifiques
ça reste une personne humaine et donc ce
n'est pas mon avis aux forces de l'ordre
de prendre la responsabilité à ce
qu'aujourd'hui on les stigmatise ils
sont stigmatisés aujourd'hui les forces
de l'ordre à cause de l'utilisation de
cette bd est donc si on veut que la
relation entre la population et les
forces de l'ordre s'améliore je pense
qu'il faut aussi de
leur donner les moyens de ne pas
utiliser ces mères si on a bien compris
votre message merci beaucoup et xavier
iacovelli d'avoir oeuvré avec nous cette
semaine d'un city bon et on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
semaine d'actualité parlementaire
[Musique]
ce soir à 22h livrer vos adèle va leur
être soit la chanteuse keren ann et le
philosophe historien de l'art georges
didi huberman suivi à 23h des dessous de
la mondialisation haïti voyage en terre
d'espoir vont annonçait désir le pays
c'est haïti
ici on est dans la partie haïtienne
bonne soirée sur public sénat
[Musique]
il aura fallu dix ans de batailles et
deux échecs successifs
mais depuis cet été c'est fait la chaîne
des puys est inscrite au patrimoine
mondial de l'humanité
une fierté pour le sénateur du
puy-de-dôme eric gold si la candidature
a finalement abouti
c'est grâce à un changement de stratégie
donc au fur et à mesure la candidature
il a fallu l'améliorer et pour
l'améliorer on s'est concentré sur un
critère scientifique on a laissé tomber
un petit peu le critère esthétique parce
que les terres esthétique c'est toujours
un peu relatif donc voilà on est on
s'est concentrés on avait des arguments
techniques et scientifiques sur ce
critère qui nous paraissait plus adapté
pour mener à bien la candidature car la
chaîne des puys présente un intérêt
scientifique et pédagogique unique au
monde
c'est un des seul lieu au monde où on
peut voir tous les processus à l'oeuvre
dans la rupture des continents
rassemblés en un lieu très restreint et
vous voyez donc d'une part la grande
faille de limagne qui marque vraiment ce
processus de cassure d'effondrement de
la de la croûte terrestre ensuite
strictement parallèle à la faille de
limagne vous avez ce remarquable
alignement de 80 volcan qui témoigne
intrinsèquement de ce lien génétique
entre l'effondrement et le volcanisme ce
paysage en forme de manuels de géologie
permet donc aux visiteurs même novices
de comprendre la formation du relief
la faille de limagne ses 35 millions
d'années et la chaîne des puys centre 95
milan et 8400 ans donc c'est le rend
très jeune à l'échelle géologique au
pied du puy de dôme le site de lemptégy
permet de poursuivre la découverte de ce
patrimoine géologique
c'est vraiment l'intérieur d'un volcan
le cratère il était au dessus
ils étaient cent mètres plus haut
longtemps exploité pour ces matériaux
l'ancien volcan est depuis 1992 ouvert
au public un décor de western qui attire
cent dix mille visiteurs par an mais
aussi de nombreux scientifiques voit
bien toutes les couches successives la
partie après au dessus
ces scories qui sont plutôt noir ça
c'est la deuxième éruption du volcan de
lemptégy qui élèvent part de son et on
peut dire que c'est un livre ouvert
grandeur nature un livre ouvert qui
s'inscrit pleinement dans l'argument
pédagogique qui a permis à la chaîne des
puys de décrocher le précieux label de
lune
ce que c'est vraiment un travail de fond
qui a été fait et de faire partie de cet
ensemble de deux volcans qui est
labellisé c'est une grande grande fierté
alors là on retrouve des souris voter
oui c'est plutôt c'est plutôt la g c'est
ça c'est très très bulot à volvic un
artiste met en valeur cette matière
volcanique
thierry courtadon ce culte de la pierre
de volvic ses oeuvres voyage dans le
monde entier
c'est une lave donc c'est une matière
très homogène et qui n'est pas très très
très dur mais par contre qui est très
fiable et c'est vrai qu'on peut se
permettre à travers à travers cette
matière d'aller sur sur un travail de
finesse assez extraordinaire
thierry courtadon était l'un des
ambassadeurs de la candidature auprès de
l'unesco
ça c'est que la terre voilà c'est que
lapierre réalisé sans trucage une
candidature axées sur le patrimoine
géologique qui s'est donc révélée
payante si l'inscription au patrimoine
mondial vaut toutes les campagnes de
promotion ce label doit aussi permettre
d'allier tourisme et préservation du
territoire
chaque année plus de 500 mille visiteurs
gravissent le puy-de-dôme
[Musique]
public sénat au coeur des territoires
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo ici au
parlement européen à bruxelles nous
sommes à 80 jours des élections
européennes et nous commençons dans
cette édition notre tour d'europe pour
situer les principaux enjeux dans
certains états membres pour notre
première escale cap à l'est dans le pays
de viktor orban
chantre de la démocratie libérale tenant
d'une ligne particulièrement dur sur
l'immigration et défenseurs d'une europe
chrétienne
notre reporter a tendu son micro aux
principales forces politiques en
présence en hongrie à quelques semaines
de ce scrutin décisif mais je vous
propose d'abord un tour d'horizon de
l'actualité européenne avec ce condensé
préparé par aurélie d'afas
[Musique]
la france le propose au niveau européen
mais elle peine à l'obtenir
si la taxation des gars phare est une
proposition au niveau continental
elle va devenir une réalité en france
les géants du numérique devrait
désormais être taxés à hauteur de 3 % de
leur chiffre d'affaires
une trentaine de groupes internationaux
seraient concernés c'étaient les
élections législatives en estonie ce
week-end le parti libéral la réforme
remporté le scrutin avec près de 29% des
voix devant le centre du premier
ministre sortant
en troisième position l'extrême droite
réalise une percée le parti
eurosceptique qui a notamment fait
campagne sur des thèmes nationalistes
réussit presque a triplé son score il
devrait désormais disposer de 31 sièges
au parlement
les élections c'est aussi ce qui
préoccupe emmanuel macron le président
français lance sa campagne pour les
européennes dans une interview à la
chaîne italienne rai uno
il a marqué la détente dans les
relations transalpine qualifiant de
simple péripétie les tensions
diplomatiques récentes en réaffirmant la
nécessité d'une europe unie du bill
downe son cap pour les élections du 26
mai nous avons besoin d'une europe plus
forte pour moi c'est le coeur de la
campagne qui s'ouvre cette campagne elle
ne doit pas être un choix entre une
ouverture béate et le retour au
nationalisme son opposition au
nationalisme il l'a réaffirmé dans une
lettre aux européens adressé aux
citoyens des 28 pays de l'union dans
leurs journaux nationaux et dans leur
langue
dans ce texte aux allures de programme
il décline une série de propositions
remettre à plat l'espace schengen créé
une banque européenne du climat pour
financer la transition énergétique ou
encore instituer un bouclier social
garantissant par exemple un salaire
minimum européen
dans son adresse emmanuel macron la
firme
l'europe est en danger mais l'europe est
nécessaire et il se positionne en
défenseur de l'europe qui protège face
aux pièges nationaliste
[Musique]
et cette tribune d'emmanuel mâcon va
chercher à l'analyser en plateau ici
avec jean sébastien lefebvre bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le spécialiste des
questions européennes pour le site
d'information contexte alors que cette
tribune est publiée par le président
français il s'adresse directement aux
citoyens européens c'est finalement un
exercice assez inédit comment ça a été
perçu dans les différentes capitales
européennes alors en effet c'est un
exercice inédit dans le sens où c'est la
première fois qu'un président de la
république s'adresse directement aux
citoyens à l'ensemble des citoyens
ça a été plus ou moins bien perçue mais
en fonction des orientations politiques
on va dire des différents leaders ou
autre on a vu par exemple premier
ministre espagnol qui est socialiste
plutôt centre centre gauche félicité le
président français pour ces propositions
est trouvé ça très bien les soutenir
même chose pour le premier ministre
belge qui le premier a réagi en disant
je suis entièrement d'accord je soutiens
ces propositions mais c'est normal
finalement parce qu'ils sont de la même
famille politique c'est aussi un
centriste libéral qu'on va retrouver
dans la famille politique des libéraux
démocrates au parlement européen alors
plus étonnant à viktor orban le premier
ministre hongrois a salué cette tribune
alors le viktor orban n'a effectivement
salué la tribune mais si on lit en
détail ce que dit le porte-parole de
victor sorbonne dans la journée il a foi
dit que de toute façon emmanuel macron
était un président pro migration que ces
mesures étaient à rejeter et c'est parce
que voilà il est promis grand il veut
déferlante migratoire donc la rhétorique
traditionnelle de budapest là dessus et
même temps ils disent oui on salue parce
que comme ça ça permet le débat on va
pouvoir discuter et c'est donc c'est un
peu comment il salue mais en même temps
ils disent clairement que ils vont pas
accepter ce qui est forcément mis sur la
table parce que par exemple sur schengen
ça ne peut pas les regrets est-ce que
selon vous à emmanuel macron se posant
en leader de l'europe avec cette tribune
indirectement oui il ya toujours cette
idée chez emmanuel macron de mener le
combat pour réformer l'europe sur le
long terme amener à faire évoluer sur
les questions de protection commerciale
de de relations avec le reste du monde
et de souveraineté européenne comme il
dit mais en même temps s'adressant
directement aux citoyens il se pose
aussi en réformateur en était en
comment dire en intermède entre les
citoyens et les dirigeants celui
finalement siège au conseil européen
donc accès à au 27 aux chefs d'état et
de gouvernement mais là il dit voilà moi
je vous proposes tu as toi il cherche du
soutien en fait finalement au delà des
cercles habituels de pouvoir et est ce
que c'est le bon moment pour publier
cette tribune selon vous et pourquoi en
terme de timing oui on est un petit peu
dans le moment où la campagne va
commencer dans les opinions publiques
des différents pays on va commencer à
parler d'europe d'élections européennes
donc puis dans le timing c'est à peu
près cc c'est assez cohérent
surtout qu'on va avoir un sommet
européen dans trois semaines où les
élections européennes ont commencé à
peser on va aussi parler du break site
le break cité dans trois semaines à peu
près donc oui on va dire que là dessus
il a bon ok cette tribune 1 c'est
finalement aussi une sorte de programme
électoral qui ne dit pas son nom est
d'ailleurs le thème de l'immigration il
ya une place de choix
alors c'est un programme électoral mais
qui va au delà des élections européennes
dans le sens où ce qu'ils proposent en
grande partie ne relève pas de la
compétence des futurs députés européens
quand il dit on va créer un conseil de
sécurité de l'europe pour gérer les
questions extérieures etc
ça c'est pas le futur député en marche
qui va pouvoir le créer c'est une
décision des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement dont il ya des mesures
clairement oui les députés pourront
voter là dessus et s'exprimer mais il ya
d'autres choses plus grande sur la
vision la réforme de l'europe où ça
c'est du débat plus large
il va au delà du cadre des simples
élections après sur les questions
migratoires effectivement il en a parlé
alors on peut voir ça comme un petit en
dire ou braquer à droite
ils essaient de de draguer en quelque
sorte l'électorat plutôt elle est rude
et y est c'est en france mais en même
temps si on regarde les lignes d'après
quand il dit je veux remettre à plat
schengen aussitôt il dit oui on va
protéger les frontières mais ça on va
dire c'est déjà le cas dans schengen et
les frontières doivent être fermées
contrôlé à l'extérieur c'est des
frontières intérieures qui ont été
enlevés mais il dit aussi solidarité et
là il ya un message à voir aussi envers
les pays de l'est où on a justement
victor sorbonne qui lui dit moi je veux
protéger les frontières mais je veux pas
de solidarité sur la question de gestion
de droit d'asile
migration etc aucun quota de répartition
à l'étoile rouge de belgrade refuse
c'est sartre et donc du coup en en
faisant le lien entre solidarité et
contrôle des frontières en fait c'est le
en même temps traditionnels d'emmanuel
mâcon c'est oui contrôle des frontières
dont qui plaît plutôt à la droite mais
il ya la solidarité à gauche alors le
problème c'est que c'est toujours plus
facile de faire la partie contrôle des
frontières que faire la partie
solidarité qui bloque car mans depuis
plusieurs années la réforme du droit
d'asile européen est complètement
bloquée à cause justement de
l'opposition des pays de l'est
cette remise à plat de l'espace schengen
est ce que ces nouveaux par rapport à
son grand discours sur l'europe à la
sorbonne en 2017
il en parlait pas de papa de cette façon
là mais il ya toujours la question
migratoire puisqu'elle revient c'est un
sujet d'actualité
dès qu'il ya plusieurs bateaux qui
arrivent via l'arrivée cette vie ni
aussi - d'extrême droite au pouvoir en
italie
donc il est obligé d'en dire de
s'emparer du sujet ce que c'est un sujet
politique au sein de l'union européenne
c'est un sujet qui est discutée entre
chefs d'état et de gouvernement donc il
est obligé de s'y intéresser surtout il
est très critiqué en france sur le sujet
comme la gauche qui dit vous n'avez pas
pris de bateaux quand les italiens
refusait d accueillir vous refuser de
prendre des migrants etc
donc c'est toujours voilà il faut qui
jongle comme il est au centre
l'échiquier politique entre les deux
alors dans cette tribune emmanuel macron
parle de repli nationaliste mais on sent
qu'il ne s'étant pas trop sur cette
opposition entre nationalistes et
progressistes il avait pourtant mis en
avant dans cette précédente prise de
parole pourquoi à votre avis je trouve
quand même qui le dit en en utilisant
briques site c'est à dire qu' il n'a pas
directement à les confronter les
nationalistes comme il le faisait
souvent via viktor orban ou via les
polonais on sent que là dessus il
cherche quand même un petit peu
apaisement n'y a pas d'opposition
frontale là mais il utilise de brick
city dit au début de la tribune dit les
gens comment les hommes politiques vous
ont menti ils vous ont dit que ce serait
génial de sortir de l'union européenne
que ce serait facile et qui aurait que
des bénéfices et regarder voilà ces gens
qui vous ont tous promis va finalement
se passe rien et on doit pas faire la
même erreur et donc du coût de cette
manière il dit voilà moi je vais vous
dire la vérité c'est ça qu'il faut faire
et c'est là qu'il amène
l'opposition entre ceux qui veulent
détruire l'europe et ceux qui veulent la
réformer mais en même temps voilà il dit
clairement on peut pas garder le statu
quo est là pour le coup c'est un message
plus vers une partie la partie nord de
l'europe
il ya de nombreux pays qui disent mais
finalement les choses vont très bien
pourquoi réformer la zone euro pourquoi
changer les règles et la macro ont dit
non ça c'est un rapace sur le long terme
il faut qu'on tire des conséquences de
watts une tribune un qui marque en tout
cas à l'entrée en campagne d'emmanuel
macro merci beaucoup d'être venus et
aujourd'hui nous éclairer sur cette
question comme promis nous prenons
maintenant la direction de budapest où
la campagne pour les européennes a déjà
commencé depuis trois semaines les murs
de la capitale sont recouverts
d'affichés particulièrement agressive
notamment à l'encontre du président de
la commission européenne
jean claude juncker ce sera peut-être la
provocation de trop pour viktor orban
qui pourrait voir sa formation le fidèle
expulsé du parti populaire européen en
attendant les sondages donnent son parti
largement gagnant face à une opposition
hongroise qui a beaucoup de mal à se
faire entendre
état des forces en présence à moins de
trois mois du scrutin avec ce reportage
signé flora sauvage
10 février 2019
viktor orban lance sa campagne pour les
élections européennes autour de son
thème de prédilection l'immigration
grand favori des sondages le premier
ministre au roi se pose en défenseur des
nations chrétiennes contre une vision
multiculturelle de l'europe
nous devons comprendre que les peuples
européens ont atteint à carrefour
historique que ceux qui décident en
faveur de l'immigration et des migrants
créée en réalité des nation métissée et
que les traditions historiques dans ces
pays sont menacés face à ce qu'il
considère comme une menace
le gouvernement hongrois a dévoilé mi
février une campagne d'affichage
agressive contre le milliardaire
d'origine hongroise george soros et le
président de la commission européenne
jean claude juncker vidéo à l'appui
viktor orban on les accuse d'un complot
pour submerger la hongrie de migrants
bruxelles un guide local des immigrants
chemise ou monaco et au canada ni aux
barrages
est-ce facile une affiche aux gangs ont
tout de même il a kiss ou bruxelles
cette vision est partagée dans la rue où
les migrants sont souvent vus comme la
bête noire c'est leur valeur leur mode
de vie leur religion qui me pose
problème
moi j'ai vu à la télévision les migrants
qui arrivent et j'ai vu leurs chefs
religieux leur dire d'occuper l'europe
et d'investir notre territoire
ils ne leur ont pas dit de s'intégrer
ils nous sont totalement étrangers je ne
pense pas que bruxelles va nous forcer à
accueillir des hordes de migrants dont
on ne veut pas mais bon on a déjà assez
d'étrangers de toute façon dans ce pays
d'europe centrale de moins de 10
millions d'habitants où l' indice de
fécondité est l'un des plus bas d'europe
les sondages promettent aux fides le
parti de viktor orban une place de
favori que personne ne semble pouvoir
lui disputer comme l'expliquent ce
politologue
ils prospèrent sur les motifs qui est le
suivant nous allons protéger la hongrie
des migrants et de bruxelles c'est un
message très populaire mais il prospère
aussi parce qu'il ya un problème
démocratique qui affecte directement les
élections car le fides a des moyens
financiers conséquents
d'ailleurs quand vous vous promenez dans
les rues de budapest vous pouvez voir de
nombreuses affiches placardées par le
gouvernement avec des messages pro fides
tandis que les partis d'opposition sont
poursuivis pour de soi-disant problème
de détournement de fonds aux fins
l'opposition hongrie a du mal à se faire
entendre
d'autant qu'un consortium géant
regroupant 476 titres pro
gouvernementaux a été créé à l'automne
2010 8
il y a un fort contrôle des médias par
le gouvernement il contrôle non
seulement la presse quotidienne
régionale mais aussi la télévision
publique
certains des médias en ligne bref une
quantité importante de la population ne
s'informe que par l'intermédiaire de ces
médias pro-gouvernementaux
ainsi au sein de la rédaction de
maillard dmz est le quotidien de
référence
on prend fait et cause à l'image du
fides pour une hongrie forte
nous sommes dans l'union européenne
c'est vrai mais c'est un continent très
varié où on ne partage pas tous les
mêmes idées et parfois ici dans l'est de
l'europe uniquement parce qu'on n'est
pas très riche et qu'on a rejoint
l'union européenne plus tard on a
vraiment le sentiment qu'on nous traite
comme des européens inférieurs à ceux de
l'ouest dans les rues de budapest
la campagne pour se départager les 21
sièges de députés européens alloués à la
hongrie a déjà commencé deuxième force
d'opposition du pays
le jobbik compte actuellement trois
députés européens
difficile de distinguer ceux qui les
oppose aux fides la protection de notre
pays et de notre civilisation contre
l'immigration illégale de masse doit
être mise en place
et dans ce but nous sommes pour le
rétablissement des gardes à nos
frontières et d'une coopération étroite
avec frontex d'autres partis
d'opposition font figure d'outsiders
organes et ceux qui partagent ses idées
contribuer à affaiblir l'europe inspiré
dans marche môme ntoum tente de faire
entendre une autre voix avec des moyens
limités
là ce sont nos bénévoles qui sont en
train de coller les stickers ce sticker
zee que vous avez le droit de savoir que
viktor orban est le hongrois le plus
riche
beaucoup de gens n'osent pas voté contre
or ban car il pense que ça peut avoir
des conséquences dans leur vie ou sur
l'avenir de leurs familles et nous
voulons leur montrer qu'il y à une
alternative
c'est ce pourquoi nous nous battons
[Musique]
prouver que môme ntoum peut être une
alternative crédible à la politique de
viktor orban
l'enjeu est de taille
[Musique]
et pour en discuter j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau sylvie
guillaume bonjour bonjour vous êtes
membre des socialistes et démocrates et
vice-présidente du parlement européen
face à vous aujourd'hui pour discuter de
ce sujet rose à thoune bonjour vous êtes
polonaise membre du parti populaire
européen
alors on va reparler de ce reportage
dans quelques instants
mais je voudrais d'abord rappeler
quelques chiffres sur la hongrie c'est
un pays qui compte un peu moins de 10
millions d'habitants son économie
représente environ 1,3 pour cent du pib
européen la hongrie a rejoint lieu en
2004 et elle compte 21 députés au
parlement européen
elle est présidée par yann hausse hader
et son premier ministre le sait c'est
viktor orban tous deux membres du fid
est un parti libéral à l'origine devenu
au fil du temps conservateur et
populiste à leur style vidyo mais on l'a
vu dans ce reportage cette campagne
d'affichage 1 particulièrement virulente
à l'encontre de jean-claude juncker le
président de la commission européenne
elle devrait être en place jusqu'à mi
mars et elle va laisser place à une
campagne qui cette fois visera france
timerman c'est le candidat de votre
parti pour les élections
oui c'est de la longue série de
provocations de la part de monsieur
urban contre l'union européenne ses
représentants donc j'espère que ces
campagnes vont être stoppés je crois que
le parti populaire européen essaye de
faire stopper cette campagne par
conviction auprès de monsieur urban ce
que sam appelle aussi comme remarque
c'est que on a quand même le sentiment
que viktor orban prend son opinion
publique pour une investi c'est à dire
ne dit des phrases très simple très
caricatural sans expliquer la réalité et
je trouve que c'est faire injure au
peuple hongrois d'en rester à des
phrases qui sont aussi pour vos quatre
ici est très fort hills et très
caricatural ensuite tout à fait et
depuis longtemps malheureusement très
bien alors rose est soudain cette
campagne d'affichage
on l'a dit on elle pose la question de
l'expulsion du fidèle du parti populaire
européen le ppe devrait d'ailleurs se
prononcer sur cette question le 20 mars
quelle est votre position sur
l'expulsion ou non du fidèle je suis
désolé mais je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec marc cozilis je suis désolé qu'il
faut critiquer tellement un groupe et un
parti les collègues qui sont ensemble
avec nous au ppe et surtout victor orban
bien sûr et c'est pas seulement à cause
de cette histoire avec l'affichage qui
est complètement incroyable et pendant
encore une fois il traverse la red line
la ligne rouge comme on dit mais leurs
provocations
c'est pas seulement les provocations
mais c'est la destruction de la
démocratie dans son propre pays et son
propre pays et le pays membres de
l'union européenne
et c'est la destruction de deux niveaux
de la démocratie dans toute l'union
européenne nous sommes un organisme
finalement un don tous cet organisme
nous devons vraiment protéger la
démocratie là le respect pour le droit
au rouleau flore comme on dit ici et
nous allons avoir une main débat très
sérieux nous avons eu déjà plusieurs et
la décision va être prise le 20 mai sur
webber a écrit une lettre au président
de ppe monsieur dole avec les conditions
plusieurs conditions sur lesquelles on
pouvait rester mais je ne vois pas
vraiment de bonne volonté
deux côtés de monsieur obama alors
justement ce sont notamment les
allemands du ppe qui semble lâcher
victor à bord ben ils étaient des
soutiens historiques du premier ministre
hongrois manfred weber on vous l'avait
dit le candidat de la droite européenne
avait félicité viktor orban pour sa
réélection en avril dernier
j'ai hâte de continuer à travailler avec
vous pour trouver des solutions communes
aux défis européens
mais le ton a changé dernièrement viktor
orban suis le mauvais chemin politique
notamment en ce qui concerne le style ou
les questions fondamentales
relative à l'ordre démocratique ce n'est
pas la voie du ppe manfred weber a
depuis déclaré qu'il se disait prêt à
accorder une dernière chance à victor
ben sylvie guillaume quelle serait votre
réaction si viktor orban restait au sein
du ppe
je trouve qu'il y à beaucoup
d'ambiguïtés beaucoup d'hypocrisie dans
ce que vous venez de rappeler de la part
d'un certain nombre de leaders du ppe
pardon mais quand j'entends que si
monsieur ban s'excuse s'il retire sa
campagne s'il s'excuse donc auprès des
autres partis après tout on pourrait
passer l'épongé
je trouve que c'est plutôt du registre
de d'un surveillant de collège qui
surveille donc des élèves qui font des
bêtises et qui leur dit bon allez on va
passer l'épongé
si vous vous excusez c'est pas à la
hauteur madame thoune avez raison de
rappeler tout à l'heure que ce qui est
en cause avec victor orban henry c'est
l'état de droit
ces attaques contre les ong c'est les
attaques contre la justice contre les
journalistes bref la séparation des
pouvoirs donc on est dans une crise
démocratique extrêmement grave on peut
pas gérer ça juste en disant
excusez-vous il ça passera il ya aussi
un argument politique puisqu'il ya douze
députés
je vais y venir deuxième ambiguïté aussi
chez les français du ppe qui finalement
regarde ça avec beaucoup de distance et
ne prennent pas parti disent que
finalement tout cela pourrait se passer
parce qu'évidemment derrière vous avez
raison il ya eu un problème majeur pour
je crois pour manfred weber qui envisage
d'être tranquille et le speed seule
candidate et envisage d'aider les dettes
dans les top job de des institutions
européennes c'est le nombre de membres
du fidesz qui viennent rejoindre ou qui
deviendrait plus rejoindre les rangs du
ppe et avec les recompositions
politiques qui peuvent intervenir avec
d'autres groupes d'autres personnalités
ouvertement eurosceptique pour ne pas
dire europhobe anti migrants dans le
parlement européen ceci pour constituer
une force alternative au ppe qui la met
en grand danger effectivement mais
certains membres du ppe ont voté pour le
déclenchement de l'article 7 8 et moi
qu'il ya eu là aussi une très grande
diversité de vote
je sais ce qu'a fait madame tout le jeu
c'est ce qu'on fait un certain nombre de
français j'essaie ce qu'on fait un
certain nombre d'allemands mais tout le
monde n'était pas sur la même position
et donc ils aiment y compris des deux
motions du pays qui ont refusé
d'enclencher de demandes et
l'enclenchement de l'article 7
donc il faut
voir les idées claires sur ce sujet il
faut que le ppe soient plus francs du
collier d'une certaine manière vis-à-vis
de ce voisin de 700 participants très
turbulent est très dangereux je crois
pour la démocratie en europe aux atomes
pour vous c'est probable que viktor
orban soient expulsés du ppe le 20 mars
je crois que c'est très probable
malheureusement c'est très probable pour
pour défendre le ppe il faut dire que
nous avons pris n'est pas pour un peu
contrôlées au calme elle fides dans ses
ambitions de détruire la démocratie
l'article 7 comme vous avez dit été
déclenché et le ppe a voté pour pour cet
article 7
moi j'ai vu la grande majorité a voté
pour déclencher l'article 7 et mails
mais ce n'est pas une décision facile je
dois avouer parce que renvoyer quelqu'un
aussi bien on travaille comme dans un
groupe des partis des des pays membres
c'est la solution la plus facile mais
quelle solution est telle qu'ils nous
sert le mieux est ce que ça va changer
organes et son parti pour mieux si on
leur envoie du groupe ppe quand il ne va
renforcer les groupes de l'extrême
droite c'est que ses 12 députés partent
dans les rangs de l'extrême droit et 12
députés vont partir je crains dans les
groupes d'extrême droite les a forcées
orban ne va pas avoir plus aucun frein
parce que là le ppe était un peu un
frein trop doux où il n'a pas respecté
j'avoue donc finalement on va se séparer
le plus probablement il va devoir
quitter le ppe mais ça ne va pas
améliorer malheureusement la situation
ni pour les hongrois
ni au parlement européen mais de l'autre
côté nous le ppe
comme les autres groupes démocratiques
nous devons tenir une ligne on ne peut
pas montrer aux citoyens européens
contre l'eire
ce genre de comportement qui est
extrêmement grave
je suis polonaise donc je sais de quoi
je parle
la pologne qui est aussi sous le coup
d'une procédure de l'article 7 ans et
une procédure qui peut mener l'état
membres incriminés à être privé de son
droit de vote au conseil et je voudrais
d'ailleurs maintenant à que l'on
s'arrête un instant sur le fameux groupe
de vice grave car il est difficile de
parler de la hongrie dans l'europe sont
l'évoqué ce groupe compte quatre états
membres de l'union européenne la hongrie
justement mais aussi la pologne la
république tchèque et la slovaquie
quatre pays d'europe centrale qui avait
choisi de se réunir en 1991 à la fin de
la guerre froide pour faciliter leur
intégration au sein de l'union
européenne et de l'otan depuis quelques
années ce groupe gagne en notoriété car
il est utilisé par ses membres pour
défendre des positions communes au sein
de l'union européenne notamment une
politique restrictive en matière
d'immigration
finalement quand on parle de dérive
démocratique en gris et rose à tout vous
avez aussi l'impression que la pologne
est sur un chemin parallèle à la hongrie
la pologne je ne dirais pas le
gouvernement je dirais oui
le parti pis il faut vraiment voir une
grande différence entre ceux qui dit la
majorité de papy polonais et ceux qui
prônent ans le parti qui est en
gouvernant maintenant parce que 84 je
crois pour cent de la part des polonais
disent oui à l'europe 18 au respect au
droit mais c'est comme ça que la
démocratie fonctionne les élections ont
montré aux ont donné la majorité on a
voté pour le parti droit et justice qui
est maintenant en un gouvernement qui
gouverne maintenant et c'est un parti
qui est qui veut avoir une autre europe
une europe où des pays membres qui sont
complètement indépendants l'un de
l'autre et il appelle sa souveraineté et
c'est vrai que nous souffrons en ce
moment et je
craint que toute l'europe s'offre
sobrement et cette procédure de
l'article 7 allée efficace selon vous
parce que l on peut vouer à l'échec
puisque il faut un vote à l'unanimité
des états membres
je comprends très bien que les autres
pays qui respecte les autres
gouvernement qui respecte l'état de
droit ne veulent pas que au conseil les
politiciens qui ne respect pas notre
droit commun en le droit de vote
alors ce groupe devise gras dans cette
vidéo on l'a vu c'est un groupe de
résistance
aujourd'hui à bruxelles ils bloquent
notamment certaines questions notamment
ce dossier migratoire on a vu que cette
réforme de l'asile et bien il était
impossible à mettre en place
oui en même temps les pays du groupe de
visegrad ne sont pas les seuls à bloquer
la réforme à l'harmonisation du droit
d'asile en europe il ya des pays qui
n'en font pas parti qui bloque aussi sur
un certain nombre de sujets mais je
crois que c'est une question
effectivement d'image aussi donné il
faut faire la distinction effectivement
sur les sanctions qu'on a envie
d'imposer à dirigeants parce qu'il a une
attitude particulièrement délétère et
l'impact que ça a effectivement sur la
population et c'est très important est
le message que moi j'aurais envie de
délivrer au peuple hongrois ou aux
tchèques et aux slovaques qui ont peu le
mais c'est qu'il faut continuer de
croire en la démocratie
il faut continuer de se renseigner sur
ce que fait l'union européenne pour lui
elle est importante dans les actions qui
sont menées auprès d'eux combien il faut
arrêter de croire sur parole un certain
nombre de faits qui sont délivrés dans
le pignon sur ben 10 il faut freiner il
faut ce qu'il faut fermer complètement
la migration en même temps il a
accueilli plus de 300 vénézuélien sur
son territoire il augmente les bourses
pour les étudiants étrangers est
manifestement sa population décroît il
ya apprend une démographique énorme
engrais donc il faut que l'on continue
nous de notre côté européen a argumenté
auprès de ses opinions publiques là pour
dénoncer effectivement les agissements
des dirigeants et faire croire aux
valeurs et aux priorités de l'europe
la hongrie un qui fera sans doute encore
beaucoup parler d'elle pendant
cette campagne pour les européennes
merci à toutes les deux d'avoir été nos
invités aujourd'hui merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis c'est ainsi que se termine
notre émission aujourd'hui mais vous
pouvez la retrouver en replay sur nos
différents sites et cpam public sénat et
rtbf.be très belle semaine à tous et à
très bientôt
[Musique]
public sénat au coeur des territoires au
nom c'est désir
le pays c'est haïti ici on est dans la
paranoïa ici et là je me suis dit ça y
est d'ailleurs essayé de faire
fonctionner un peu le tourisme haïtien
qui en pleine émergence
enfin en train de deux nouveaux pliage
aujourd'hui après le stage en juillet
beaucoup d'entre eux pourront trouver un
emploi et bien que des foires c'est pas
permanent mais au fur et à mesure qu'ils
se trouvent en emploi comment bienvenue
au musée je suis katia je suis votre
guide pour aujourd'hui je pense que ça
fait partie de ce qu haïti à offrir au
tourisme et qu'il faut faire connaître
c'est la première république noire parce
que c'est la première république a été
un des panneaux dans le monde les
dessous de la mondialisation haïti
voyage en terre d'espoir ce soir à 23h
sur public sénat
[Musique]
découvrez votre programme sur public
sénat avec leboncoin emploi cadres
[Musique]
bienvenue dans le magazine de l'emploi
une demi heure pour répondre à toutes
les questions très concrètes que vous
vous posez en matière d'emploi mais
aussi de reconversion et de formation
comment passe-t-on du métier de
rédactrice web la décoratrice
d'intérieur la réponse c'est cécile qui
va nous la donner si avec cette
reconversion elle a choisi de vivre de
sa passion son changement de vie a été
minutieusement préparé les conseils et
très pratique pour chercher du travail
cet arthur père ticos qui nous les
donnent aujourd'hui on reprend du début
trouvé un boulot oui et park on commence
professionnels de santé techniciens et
conseiller commercial l'opticien et tout
ça à la fois si vous êtes méticuleux et
que vous avez le sens du contact ce
métier est peut être fait pour vous vous
en serez vraiment sûr après avoir
partagé une journée avec romain et ça
vaut le coup d'oeil
comment faciliter l'entrée sur le marché
du travail des personnes handicapées
c'est le problème que tente de résoudre
depuis plus de quinze ans l'association
handisup auvergne en multipliant les
initiatives
avec souvent beaucoup de succès
des expériences partager des conseils
mais aussi des outils pour décoder le
monde du travail
c'est le magazine de l'emploi et ça
commence tout de suite plein sud pour
notre rubrique territoire nous allons en
haute garonne au coeur de la ville des
pionniers de l'aviation l'industrie de
l'aéronautique tient toujours une part
importante mais pas seulement
positionnement géographique gastronomie
qualité de vie population cosmopolite
l'agglomération est réputée pour être
l'une des plus dynamiques de france
vous l'aurez compris on vous emmène à
toulouse son accent chantant son
capitole ses briques et son canal du
midi à toulouse
bienvenue à toulouse au nord de la haute
garonne
[Musique]
bon là il pleut mais d'habitude ce
territoire est baignée de soleil
et ce n'est pas michel caujolle
directeur territorial de pôle emploi qui
viendra nous contredire
l'attractivité géographique de toulouse
on la retrouve à la fois avec sa
proximité de l'autre côté des pyrénées
avec l'espagne il ya également tout un
essor qui lié à la proximité de la
méditerranée à proximité de l'atlantique
[Musique]
que toulouse c'est une ville où il fait
bon vivre tout simplement et donc ça
attire les populations et et de fait
beaucoup d'activités se sont installés
sur toulouse même si le tourisme est
encore un sujet sur lequel toulouse peut
beaucoup progresser
si la ville est fière moyennement les
touristes elle cultive en revanche une
stabilité économique
le territoire affiche un taux de chômage
inférieur à la moyenne nationale aun
aussi frontalement toulouse aéronautique
est aujourd'hui l'aéronautique
même si on a une visibilité à près de
dix ans c'est quand même quelque chose
d'assez unique pérenne et protecteur
pour l'enfant c'est un territoire un
petit peu protégés et donc on a
généralement des collations prend
l'exemple de la crise de 2008
toulouse a été impactée avec un décalage
de six mois pour accompagner les
demandeurs d'emploi dans l'évolution
numérique l'organisme a mis en place une
politique digital propres quartiers
prioritaires
on a mis en oeuvre d'expérimentations
qui permet de délivrer des chèques
numérique
chaque chèque correspond à un service et
les données d'emploi peuvent ainsi
bénéficier d'un sound association aidant
une formation d'accompagnement à
développement de leurs compétences
numériques
si je comprends bien la ville rose
serait donc protégée en partie par
l'industrie aéronautique
les veinards pas étonnant qu'ils aient
la tête dans les étoiles
allons voir ça de plus près
rendez vous chez derichebourg atis un
groupe de sous-traitance aéronautique
créée dans les années 50 son directeur
opérationnel nous accueille au sein de
son centre de formation au sein de ce
groupe e il existe une pôle aéronautique
qui regroupe trois entités un centre de
formation une société de travail
temporaire est une société qui offre des
services industriels aux plus grands
constructeurs aéronautiques mondiaux à
ses équipementiers mais aussi aux
compagnies aériennes et aux loueurs
d'avions
[Musique]
une passion aéronautique qui peut vous
amener au delà des frontières de la
haute garonne
nous proposons des évolutions
professionnelles via des passerelles
métier nous pouvons aussi proposer des
évolutions managériale à nos salariés
80% de nos managers sont issus de la
promotion interne
on atteint des gens rigoureux impliqué
évidemment la passion érotique est un
plus et ça aide a évolué au travers de
votre entreprise
en attendant ici à toulouse ses
intégrateurs cabine en formation
apprennent à assurer l'installation de
l'équipement électrique des sièges ainsi
que de l'habillage à bord nous sommes
donc implanté sur sur toulouse mais
aussi nationalement à saint nazaire et à
marseille ainsi qu'au niveau de
l'international via nos filiales en
espagne en allemagne en chine aux usa et
au canada
préparez votre passeport carte
d'embarquement s'il vous plaît car
l'entreprise engage des électriciens des
ajusteurs et des mécaniciens des
inspecteurs qualité des préparateurs
méthode des responsables projets des
intégrateurs cabine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gardons tout de même les pieds sur terre
et direction le quartier de matabiau
pour rencontrer la start up school move
ici on prépare son brevet et son bac
alors un peu de sérieux
l'entreprise met à disposition en ligne
pour les élèves de la sixième à la
terminale
un accompagnement scolaire sous forme de
tutos de quiz et de tests
j'ai eu l'idée de ce que nous quand
j'avais 18 ans je passais mon
baccalauréat
j'avais pas forcément les moyens de me
payer des cours particuliers et mon
premier réflexe comme la plupart de mes
camarades c'était de regarder en ligne
et à l'époque j'ai été assez surpris en
fait du manque de contenu qu'on pouvait
trouver directement en ligne et c'est là
où je me suis dit ça serait bien entendu
créer la première plateforme
d'accompagnement scolaire here on
travaille plus une centaine
d'enseignants de l'éducation nationale
qui collaborent sur le projet à qui on
va commander des contenus de cours qu'on
va ensuite revérifier en interne publié
directement sur notre site et qui va
être aussi transmis directement à notre
équipe de production
l'équipe de production elle va tourner
des vidéos en studio avec des acteurs on
va ensuite les montées les animés pour
les rendre dynamique et les publier
aussi sur la plate forme pour que les
élèves puissent apprendre grâce à ses
vidéos
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
cours de physique-chimie si le cadre est
bonne enfant chez mm picardo prend à
coeur sa démarche pédagogique
par contre il faut pas se tromper la
philosophie start-ups et pas forcément
arriver tard le matin à partir quand on
veut ne pas avoir de ne pas avoir de
limites et c'est justement on a quand
même une mission qui est éducative que
pédagogique
il ya plein personne aussi et notamment
toutes les personnes qui nous ont
rejoints qui sont très motivés à l'idée
d'aider justement les jeunes à réussir
leur année scolaire
c'est très studieux ici avec modération
bien sûr
on va aussi avoir des événements un peu
plus décontracté on va retrouver toutes
les équipes pour aller boire des bières
autour de deux soirées rencontres entre
équipes que nous on appelle les récrés
school move sonne la fin de la récré
pour nous en tout cas
mais avant de partir c'est chez que
l'entreprise cherche de nouveaux talents
on recrute actuellement d'ailleurs
quatre postes stratégiques le premier
qui est un producteur manager idéalement
avec une expertise mobile le deuxième
c'est directeur commercial pour nous
aider justement à développer le chiffre
d'affaires
le troisième c'est 8 designer donc c'est
quelqu'un qui se concentre plutôt sur la
partie des interfaces mobiles
et des stops et enfin un développeur on
cherche notamment un développeur senior
donc il ya pas mal d'expérience pour
rejoindre les postes qui peuvent vous
intéresser que vous soyez dans la région
ou pas
si ces offres d'emploi vous intéresse
vous pouvez retrouver les contacts des
entreprises sur la page de l'émission
via le site publicsenat.fr
cqfd ce qu'il faut décoder c'est notre
guide pratique pour tout comprendre des
acronymes et des expressions pas
toujours très clair que l'on rencontre
dans le monde du travail et c'est tout
cqfd ce qu'il faut décoder
vous avez acquis des compétences au
cours de votre vie professionnelle et
vous est même très qualifiés dans votre
domaine mais il n'y a pas de diplôme
pour officialiser votre savoir faire
devant un recruteur pourquoi ne pas
tenter d'obtenir un cqp et allons bon
mais qu'est ce que c'est le cqp est un
certificat qui atteste officiellement
qu'une personne possède les
qualifications et les compétences
nécessaires à l'exercice d'un métier en
milieu professionnel
par exemple il n'existe pas de diplôme
délivré par l'éducation nationale pour
être pizzaïolo mélasse de la pizza peut
faire reconnaître son savoir faire et sa
capacité à exercer dans un restaurant
grâce à un cqp même chose pour un
peintre anticorrosion un négociateur
immobilier ou un agent de sécurité
délivré par les différentes branches
professionnelles les cqp permettent de
répondre aux besoins spécifiques d'un
secteur le cqp est accessible aux jeunes
aux salariés comme aux demandeurs
d'emploi il peut être obtenu après une
formation où grâce à la vae la
validation des acquis de l'expérience
dans les deux cas le candidat doit
constituer un dossier qui sera évalué
par un jury composé de professionnels et
de formateurs selon votre situation
plusieurs interlocuteurs peuvent vous
aider dans vos démarches
votre employeur ou un référent vae pour
les salariés un conseiller pôle emploi
pour les chômeurs ou directement les
organismes de formation
si vous reprenez vos études sur le cv et
sur le marché du travail
le cqp est un vrai atout cqfd
[Musique]
cécile à 31 ans rédactrice pour un site
culinaire bien connu à la choisit de
changer de vie pour se consacrer à la
décoration
une passion qui l'a motivé pour
retourner à l'école et devenir
décoratrice d'intérieur elle a su
construire pied à pied sa reconversion
elle vient nous raconter comment elle a
négocié en prenant des risques mais
aussi avec beaucoup de sagesse ce virage
professionnel
moi je sais c'est là non je alors vous
avez commencé votre carrière
professionnelle en tant que rédactrice
culinaire pour un site internet bien
connu et vous avez choisi de changer de
métier qu'est ce qui a motivé sa
décision plusieurs choses je pense que
déjà je n'étais pas spécialement fait
pour ce que je faisais à la base et puis
j'avais vraiment envie de me lancer dans
l'entreprenariat et de travailler pour
moi et surtout de me sentir plus utile
au quotidien en fait
[Musique]
et donc vous êtes devenu décoratrice
d'intérieur à quel moment vous vous êtes
dit je vais je vais en faire mon métier
en fait c'était assez évident c'est
quelque chose que j'ai toujours eu en
moi et mes dans ma famille voilà j'ai
aussi une soeur qui aiment beaucoup ça
une grand mère passionnée de déco et je
les ai toujours été mais j'ai jamais
pensé pour un métier et je pense que
vous considériez que c'était pas un
métier ça vous avez peur et l'esprit en
fait c'est à dire que j'avais pas pensé
pour moi parce que je sais pas dans ma
famille on n'est pas du tout dans les
métiers créatifs et j'ai pas pensé une
seconde est en fait t'es que j'ai eu
l'idée je me suis dit c'est ça
dans ma tête c'était un peu le bazar et
puis un moment donné je me suis dit
allez c'est parti lance toi alors se
lancer ça passe par quitter l'entreprise
dans laquelle vous étiez à ce moment là
c'est ça comment ça se passe pas comme
je suis un peu trouillard du pensent ils
présentent ou prudente
ça dépend comment on voit la chose mais
j'ai eu besoin de temps donc j'ai mis du
temps à partir parce que c'était une
grosse décision pour moi et j'en ai
discuté avec les responsables longuement
et puis à un moment donné ils ont
compris que j'étais plus du tout
épanouie que je commençais à être pas
bien non
donc j'ai pu négocier un départ une eau
pure conventionnelle à et partir dans de
bonnes conditions avec le temps pour
réfléchir me poser un peu et faire le
point sur ma vie professionnelle
en quoi ça consiste concrètement le
métier de décoratrice d'intérieur
globalement je dis que je suis designer
d'intérieur pas ce que je fais à la fois
la décoration d'intérieur et pays la
partie plus architecture d'intérieur ça
va être la réflexion sur l'espace faire
des plans réfléchir à comment on aménage
un appartement une maison et derrière ça
peut aller jusqu'au bout
jusqu'au moindre détail les rideaux les
tissus les coussins une formation de
décoratrice d'intérieur ça alors j'ai
fait une formation via le greta l'école
boulle c'est très court on a quatre mois
à l'école donc des gens retournent sur
les bancs de l'école c'est assez bizarre
c'est assez complet ya ça passe par
l'histoire de l'art des cours de dessin
de perspectives l'apprentissage des
logiciels pour faire des plans pour
faire des visuels 3d des choses comme ça
que j'avais jamais fait avant le fait
justement d'être totalement étrangère à
cette formation là avec peut-être des
personnes qui avait peut-être fait les
beaux-arts avant ou des métiers
peut-être plus en lien avec la formation
s'appelait des ressentis comme en moi
j'avais jamais dessiné et il y avait des
personnes qui dessinaient très bien donc
on se regarde un peu c'est en bon et
encore du travail après chacun ses
forces et ses faiblesses aussi à noter
que des filles de 25 à 45 ans deux
milieux totalement différent et avec des
envies différentes donc en fait c'est
plus soutenue je me suis fait des amis
aussi alors de la formation donc c'était
très chouette ça a été difficile de
trouver les financements vous avez
réussi à vous organiser
ça a été très difficile j'ai passé
plusieurs mois essuyé les refus
et puis au bout d'un moment j'ai eu un
oui miraculeux car sporting est pas on
m'a dit que c'était voilà les budgets
formation qui avait été réouvert parent
magie et je suis me suis engouffré dans
la brèche comment ça se passe pour
trouver des clients quand on vient
d'arriver sur le marché les premiers
clients ça a été vraiment du réseau
personnel et professionnel un petit peu
mais surtout personnelle et puis après
ça c'est fait je m'étais mis en tête de
faire une stratégie de prospection
j'avais plusieurs idées en tête et puis
j'ai par chance j'ai pas eu besoin
encore de la mettre en place
et c'est vrai que ça s'est fait tout
seul vous gagnez moins bien mieux votre
envie j'ai été au même niveau tous les
bus déjà je m'y attendais pas je m'étais
dit que choses qui seraient au nombre ma
vie en étant auto entrepreneurs oui
exactement et après j'avais pas un
salaire mirobolant avoir non plus donc
je n'étais pas non plus 13 mai
là je suis contente vraiment j'ai
dépassé largement ce que je gagnais
avant quel bilan vous tiré de cette
expérience qu'est ce que ça vous a
appris sur vous même qu'il faut jamais
lâcher faut pas avoir peur du changement
même si c'est quand même pas évident sur
le moment j'avais un peu ça en moi et je
n'ai jamais écouté vraiment donc
s'écouter plus peut-être merci c'est
sciés pour ces témoignages merci alors
où vous ne cherchez pas une reconversion
mais on travaille cv lettre de
motivation veille sur les sites de
petites annonces on voit bien ce qu'il
faut faire mais par où on commence la
réponse c'est arthur partie coquine la
dame vous pensez sérieusement à changer
de boulot ou vous y être sérieusement
obligé la motivation est là la question
si on commence par quoi on commence par
vous ce n'est pas nombriliste c'est
essentiel posez vous les bonnes
questions
qu'avez vous retiré de vos expériences
professionnelles précédentes
quelles sont les compétences que vous
maîtrisez bref en quoi êtes-vous bon
mais aussi qu'aimez vous faire dans
quelles missions vous épanouissez vous
et enfin quels sont vos exigences pour
votre prochain post
ce bilan va vous être utile au moins
quatre fois dans votre démarche
côté cv vous est maintenant capable de
faire le tri dans vos expériences pour
mettre en avant celles qui sont en phase
avec le poste recherché
vous ne savez pas encore qui sera votre
employeur mais vous savez ce que vous en
attendez la taille la mission la
clientèle les horaires les tâches le
style de gestion les perspectives de
promotion vous avez identifié ce qui est
important pour vous et donc vous ciblez
mieux vos candidatures spontanées pour
les offres d'emploi votre auto
évaluation permet de sélectionner plus
rapidement celles qui correspondent à
votre profil enfin vous avez maintenant
une liste d'arguments prête à utiliser
dans vos lettres de motivation et face
aux recruteurs
avec ce bilan de compétences et non vie
vous pouvez viser un nouvel objectif
professionnel cohérent réaliste et
motivant et voilà le travail
cette semaine dans notre rubrique métier
nous vous emmenons en immersion chez un
professionnel de santé qui est aussi un
commercial et un technicien
toutes ces compétences romain les a
acquises puisqu'il est opticien pour
découvrir les nombreuses facettes de son
métier nous l'avons suivi toute une
journée et rien que pour vos yeux
je me suis un petit peu perdues en
sortant du bac non j'avais passé un bac
scientifique
les partis en école d'ingénieur ou
médecine voilà comme beaucoup et en
discutant avec le père d'un ami qui
était un opticien
j'ai trouvé ça c'est sympa et puis de
combat je me suis dis bah pourquoi pas
et puis j'ai décidé de me lancer dans le
bts opticien lunetier on donne est
simple
[Musique]
un petit régal ça glisse un petit peu le
bts opticien lunetier ces deux ans en y
rentrant général après le bac
on apprend principalement tous qui
analyse de la vision se dire tout ce qui
peut être défaut visuel faire tous les
calculs bas pour pouvoir en effet trouvé
les bonnes corrections et ben voilà la
cedh vrille à 3 qu'elle voit pas de
problème et puis on apprend le côté
technique donc à maîtriser la taille des
verts tout ce qui est entre guillemets
vente va venir par la suite on va la
prendre vraiment en magasin en
commençant va compter ou peut avoir dans
les 1500 1600 m
et ça va monter petit à petit je pense
qu'on va dire entre 1500 et 2500 en tant
qu'employé moi j'ai toujours bien aimé
le côté le contact humain
le relationnel avec le client pouvoir
l'aider mon but en optique étant
vraiment pouvoir lui proposer quelque
chose pour qu'ils soient bien à l'aise
et qui voit bien bonjour ou demander un
petit peu justement la personne de quoi
var a besoin c'est à dire pour son
activité est ce qu'elle va revenant de
regarder beaucoup le loin est ce qu'elle
est plutôt sur écran toute la journée
pour un garagiste par exemple qui va
être souvent la tête à l'envers et enfin
d'avoir une vision très dans le haut du
verre c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas
commun du tout quand on est là personne
n'en reviennent pas je vois très bien
c'est super merci voilà je suis je suis
très content est arrivé
cette nuit-là dû rouler sur ses lunettes
petite chute l'a donc petit une petite
case de lunettes d'espionner
complètement et vous faire ça pour cet
après-midi ou un petit dépannage que ça
qu'ils puissent au moins les mettre là
voilà qui d'autant qu'on est les autres
il faut que ce soit important c'est que
la monture se pose bien qu asus bien les
sourcils qu'elle ne touche absolument
pas les pommettes et la largeur soit
bonne donc est là dessus on va arriver
en effet leur disant assez rapidement si
l'ennemi aliments tueur prenez pas celle
ci parce qu'en effet la taille totale de
la monture n'est pas en adéquation avec
votre visage
[Musique]
même si on essaie de s'immiscer un petit
peu dans la vie des personnes c'est en
effet c'est pas pour savoir ce qu'ils
font et elle répété à tous les autres
commerçants c'est pour apporter un
service et une réponse à leurs maisons
parce que je vois ce que je prends deux
trois petites mesures je vais vérifier
les diamètres exactement utile pour voir
si c'est jouer en groupe à paris v de
s'énerve un petit peu on se calme on se
pose un petit peu au un petit café on
recommence à zéro c'est le trap récit
quand même à wels avec sanary vraiment
faire des choses pas du tout on va faire
une vente
on a commandé après derrière notre
verrier un palais d'où un verre avec tel
diamètre de telles puissances
ils vont nous l'envoyer on va recevoir
un verrou entre guillemets rond qui va
falloir nous accès et puis taillez pour
pouvoir le mettre et faire entrer en
effet dans la monture
quand il achète un équipement s'est pas
non plus que le prix de la monture du
verre ça va être aussi tout le travail
qu'on va faire lors de la découpe des
réparations quand votre lunette perm
petite vie ça se desserre ça tout ça ou
qu'elle se défende un petit peu on va
les remettre en forme on va les remettre
bien droite sur vous là il vaut mieux
avoir des mondiaux des bonnes lunettes
pour le faire moi j'adore ce côté là
c'est vrai que j'aurais du mal avec mon
métier si je ne faisais qu'une seule
partie du métier cirque et j'étais que à
la vente ou que à l'atelier c'est
quelque chose qui pourrait me déplaire
[Musique]
alors je faire pour vos lunettes je
voulais mettre côté je voulais rendre et
juste après armez-vous façon être
confortable on va regarder l'écran qui
est dernièrement
j'avoue passer l'appareil pour vous
sortez de l'école vous avez le droit en
effet de pratiquer des examens de vue
vérifiez la correction de quelqu'un que
si cette personne une ordonnance sont
maintenant en effet il faut
principalement pas ces choses-là logis
c'est à dire que l'on n'a plus le droit
de faire grand chose
donc ça je trouve ça un petit peu
dommage en effet en soi un peu bloqué
effectifs ont encore un petit peu aussi
les bibelots cazade ft nous on s'amuse
énormément alors on prend plaisir à
travailler nous ramons le faire là on
arrive le matin on est content on a le
sourire
et en plus on a une plutôt une très très
bonne ambiance au magasin peut-être
regarder si on aime branche dépannage
politique excuses à ce que peut la
mettre dedans ou pas en attendant
le métier ne sera pas le même dans
toutes les boutiques en très grandes
chaînes on va être un peu moins libres
parce que tout est un petit peu plus
carré un peu plus pensé pour aller plus
vite
ah non indépendant totalement dire quand
on n'a pas de franchise coopérative on
n'appartient à personne
donc c'est lui qui l'ont tous les choix
en magasin a certes un fonceur votre un
peuple créateur de un peu classique tout
savoir des formes rondes et forme un peu
papillon d et e on peut arriver à
trouver un peu dans toutes les marques
après ce qu'on aime bien ses alliés ce
côté ci avec la qualité du produit on a
bien un bras du titane et petites choses
comme ça avec des produits qui vont
changer qui vont être plus technique
plus léger à lyme ou d'amour vraiment du
métier c'est avoir vraiment une forme
combinée à des produits de qualité vous
souhaite rester le plus longtemps
possible opticien à 1 je souhaite
vraiment j'aimerais bien en effet
reprendre un magasin parce que gérer
vraiment l'ensemble donc et le commerce
et apprend en effet gérer ce qu'il ya
dedans mais tenir la boutique me plaît
beaucoup
et donc ça que si je pouvais le faire du
site un deux ou trois ans maintenant
kopitar je le ferai je me prépare tout
ça merci merci beaucoup
bonne journée à bientôt
elles sont souvent le chaînon manquant
sur le marché de l'emploi
elle met en oeuvre des solutions
concrètes adaptées est proche du terrain
chaque semaine le magazine de l'emploi
met en avant des associations et
initiatives solidaires les personnes en
situation de handicap sont encore bien
trop souvent éloignés de l'emploi
depuis plus de quinze ans l'association
handi suppôts vergne multiplie les
actions dans la région pour faciliter
leur entrée dans le monde du travail
il nous explique comment nous les
accompagnons tout au long de l'année
dans leur projet de stage par exemple en
les adore exiger un cv les aidant à
définir des entreprises cibles et des
fonctions publiques qui peuvent les
accueillir en stage en alternance et
jusqu'à un emploi durable
nous organisons aussi un grand forum
emploi handicap qui est ouvert là pas
seulement aux jeunes en situation de
handicap mais aussi à des adultes en
reconversion professionnelle des
personnes qui sont la recherche d'une
solution de formation d'une solution
d'emploi
quelles sont les conséquences concrètes
de l'action de handisup auvergne pour le
savoir le mieux c'est de demander à ceux
qui ont bénéficié de son aide précieuse
et je suis déficientes visuelles
profonde c'est pour ça que je suis
accompagné de mon cher guy ritchie qui
m'emmène au travail tous les matins et
me ramène chez moi tous les soirs je
suis actuellement assistant rh au sein
du centre france portage cet emploi je
les ai pas trouvés grâce au dernier
forum emploi handicap et organiser nos
parents dit sup où j'ai déposé à
différents cv dans différentes
entreprises
quelque temps après j'ai été contacté
non pour façades entretiens de
recrutement voilà maintenant j'ai enfin
l'emploi j'ai autant d'avoir enfin
trouvé un travail et qu'on met enfin
donné ma chance parce que c'est pas
faute d'avoir cherché
pendant plusieurs années mais je
trouvais pas c'est que c'est un peu
compliqué de trouver un emploi quand on
est en situation de handicap active
auprès des lycéens comme des entreprises
ou des acteurs de la formation
professionnelle handisup auvergne
déploie son activité sur tous les
terrains de leur orientation
al embauche nos actions sont ouvertes
gracieusement à leur service et suffit
nous avons nous prenons rendez vous nous
voyons les démarches qu'ils ont
effectués et nous appuyons dans les
démarches jusqu'à jusqu'à ce que ça
fonctionne pour eux si vous souhaitez
contacter handisup auvergne ou si vous
êtes une association et que vous
souhaitez présenter votre initiative
toutes les infos sont évidemment à
retrouver sur la page de l'émission sur
le site publicsenat.fr
l'agenda ce sont les événements
rendez-vous et bons plans sélectionnés
dans toute la france par le magazine de
l'emploi sait comment prendre un papier
un crayon de noter dans votre smartphone
vous êtes étudiants majeurs est à la
recherche d'un emploi saisonnier c'est
tombe bien la 26e édition des journées
jobs d'été démarrent le 21 mars à paris
vous devriez trouver facilement votre
bonheur parmi les 8000 offres proposées
par la cinquantaine d'entreprises et
d'associations présentes sur le salon
mais jobs allant de vendeurs à
surveillant de baignade tout en passant
par animateurs
[Musique]
organisé par la région occitanie pôle
emploi et les missions locales le 28
mars à mende le salon taf travail avenir
formation vous guide dans votre vie
professionnelle
que vous souhaitiez définir votre projet
professionnel vous réorienter ou trouver
un emploi
les nombreuses entreprises présentes
vous viendront en aide un conseil
munissez vous de vos cv et allez-y le
plus tôt possible afin de maximiser vos
chances et
[Musique]
et pour finir cette émission nous
retournons à toulouse développé par le
groupe business est financé par la
région
l'application annie fonctionne comme une
appli de rencontre avec un but bien
différent mettre en relation directe
candidats à l'apprentissage et
recruteurs en occitanie découverte d'une
tpe ou d'un grand groupe
entraînement à l'entretien d'embauché
mise en avant de sa motivation
podcast vidéo je manie propose aussi aux
candidats de se former par des contenus
multimédias et ludique
le magazine de l'emploi c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
avec des conseils pratiques des infos
utiles et de nouvelles expériences
motivante
à bientôt
[Musique]
public sénat au coeur des territoires
oeuvres d'art mais aussi télévision
photographie métaphore littéraire
les images sont partout tout le monde
vit d'image toute la nuit on se fait des
images dans les rêves
quand on fait un tableau on fait une
image quand on fait une photo on fait
une image et ses bleus au féminin fait
tellement beau en français quand on peut
se permettre d'avoir c'est pas toutes
les couleurs déjà on dit que le bleu y
est plutôt froid et bleu rouge et chaud
mais moi je pense que le bleu les crues
de choses ça peut brûler c'est une
sensation le bleu l'or il ya une
histoire symbolique des couleurs tout ce
que vous voudrez mais la tourelle le
bleu c'est la flamme
ce qui serait pas mal propres sensations
on donne une atmosphère psychique à tout
ce qu'on voit et quand on donne une
atmosphère psychique comme vous le
faites à ces salles imagination vivez
vous avec georges didi huberman et keren
ann
ce soir à 22h sur public sénat
constitutionnellement on n'existe pas et
je trouve ça très bien
moi je me suis tracer une sorte de
mission mais je me suis tracé tout seul
suppose que moi j'ai envie envie que de
tricoter pendant 14 ans j'aurais
tricoter quand elles étaient tenus
d'aller dans un voyage officiel ce que
le faisait bah oui on parle de quoi dans
la voiture quand on on passe la journée
pendant que ces messieurs discuter que
nous on vous emmène voir les musées
bonjour à la main le bush
vous avez entendu parler des cures de
vous c'est intéressant ça elles
saisissent les opportunités qui
permettait à son point d'avancé parce
que vous voyez je suis fier lancé
danielle mitterrand une certaine idée de
la france demain à 21h sur public sénat
constitutionnellement on n'existe pas et
je trouve ça très bien moi je me suis
tracer une sorte de mission mais je me
suis tracé tout seul suppose que moi
j'ai envie envie que de tripoter pendant
14 ans j'aurais très cotés
le parti doit justice appelée pis en
pologne à accéder au pouvoir
un vif conflit politique divise la
société et le pays commence à changer de
visage
que se passe-t-il vraiment où se
dirigent la pologne
céline casse du grand paris express est
ce qu'ils veulent nous transperce et non
pas une station en souterrain qui
pourrait nous satisfaire
mais une garde en extérieur avec le
lever temps encore et toujours et donc
ils vont détruire tous les valises une
relation qu on entoure le pâté de maison
qui le projet de gare lille et déjà
entériné et de toute façon ils vont au
fil d'or
le marché immobilier et lehman brothers
ont provoqué un tel désastre sur toute
la planète gratin et même ici aux
etats-unis l'un des gens dorment dans
leur voiture avec leurs enfants tout ça
parte humidité nous ce qui nous a fort
nous c'est notre avenir et notre avenir
on lui donnera une chance sur des mares
de boue qui est pour mais plus tard je
vous aide
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça vous regarde présentée par myriam
encaoua dans un instant est-ce que la la
la forme ne dessert pas le fond c'est
comme si on mettait toutes à égalité
c'est pas facile pour un gouvernement de
changer complètement la règle du jeu que
tu sais déjà
si charles a fait dérisoire c'est comme
le ministre de l'intérieur mais ce que
vous entendez quand même que l'instant
politique est grave
ce qui importe france à ses choeurs
sécurité soit assurée que vous savez
vous peut-être c'est toujours deux poids
deux mesures n'ayons pas peur des mots
présentée par valérie brochard ce soir à
20h30 bonsoir à tous ravis de vous
retrouver soyez les bienvenus dans ça
vous regarde au sommaire ce soir
l'égalité professionnelle hommes femmes
est elle en marche depuis 15h40 en tous
les cas nous les femmes nous travaillons
gratuitement alors en ce 8 mars journée
internationale des droits des femmes va
s'interroger sur ce nouvel outil mis en
place dans les grandes entreprises d'un
index d'égalité une notation sur 100 en
fonction de cinq critères pour les
contraindre ces grandes entreprises a
avancé qui sont les bons et les mauvais
élèves peut tout faire confiance à ces
entreprises font jouer vraiment jeu
notre grand débat à suivre avec un
invité un imam qui prend l'initiative
d'une réunion publique dans les
quartiers nord de marseille un élu
municipal on perd communiste à malakoff
qui ouvre un débat très anti macron vous
à des lois nouvel échantillon de ces
paroles citoyennes dans ça fait le débat
notre mag hebdo sur la route du grand
débat national alors qu'ils président on
prépare les esprits sur les réponses du
gouvernement forcément en deçà des
attentes immenses ça c'est le débat à
découvrir dans la deuxième partie de
cette émission et puis comme chaque soir
vient surtout vous rendez vous plus
belle la politique ahmed tazir et un
extrait des mois et des mois vous allez
le voir la députée sophie auconie ne
serait pas à l'assemblée si elle avait
écouté son entourage féminin commence
autorisée à prendre le pouvoir c'est un
peu la question du du soir ce vendredi
ça vous regarde vous avez un programme
astag sévère n'oubliez pas
nous attendons nous attendons vos
réactions en direct dans cette émission
bienvenue sur ce plateau m'arrêter rex
un bon soir vous êtes député la
république en marche de l'essonne
présidente de la délégation aux droits
des femmes et à l'égalité des chances
entre les hommes et les femmes à
l'assemblée
vous étiez aux premières loges dans
l'hémicycle pour défendre cette loi dont
nous allons parler ce soir loi de
septembre 2018 qui met en place ce
fameux index d'égalité homme femme
nathalie bard great bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes associé au sein de
l' agence grand thornton france groupe
d'audit et de conseil financier votre
entreprise est la plus de 1000 salariés
et vous avez piloté la mise en place de
ce fameux nouvel outil cet index de
l'égalité dans votre entreprise vous
allez nous expliquer si ça marche
et comment ça se passe concrètement et
puis vous avez aussi piloté une autre
étude alors beaucoup plus large roumaine
est une business sur les femmes ont
entreprises dans 35 pays
vous nous direz enfin j'accueille sedin
pic bonsoir merci d'être là vous êtes
porte parole de l'association osez le
féminisme ce nouvel index est il
pertinent
y at il une véritable volonté politique
nouvelle pour avancer sur ce terrain
vous nous direz je vous donne la parole
à toutes les trois platon stato 100%
féminin ce soir on a du temps pour
débattre mais d'abord bonsoir ahmed
tazir bonsoir myriam j'espère que vous
êtes en pleine forme et pas trop
impressionné par toutes ces femmes en
force ce soir une femme justement à
l'honneur ce soir dans votre billet plus
belle la politique
aïssa d'oumar à lauréate du prix simone
veil
[Musique]
8 mars et encore des jeunes femmes
peuvent être harcelé viol et la violence
sexuelle s'exerce dans les beaux
quartiers comme dans les hlm dans les
usines comme dans les start up dans la
presse comme au cinéma des paroles se
libèrent pas assez l'oppression
masculine est une réalité dans les actes
dans les mots le une marque doit être un
combat de chaque jour en france et
partout dans le monde emmanuel macron a
remis ce matin le premier prix simone
veil à qu'il a créé pour récompenser des
actions partout dans le monde en faveur
des droits des femmes prix remis à la
camerounaise à estado marrane gâte en
dessous 1 qui gère une association des
deux victimes de viols et de mariage
forcé dans son pays
un engagement de plus de 20 en service
des femmes à mener dans le silence
parfois dans l'opprobre
elle s'est souvent indignée mais n'a pas
cédé un exemple de courage celui de
remettre en cause le poids des héritages
a dit d'elle le président de la
république je vous propose d'écouter à
la lauréate elle raconte avec ces mots
l'histoire de quelques succès qu'elle a
obtenus dans la lutte contre les
mariages forcés et les violences faites
aux femmes
c'est l'histoire de cette petite que je
pourrais nommer haddou qui dans le
mariage avait déjà été organisée à la
veille de son nom t1 classe de 6e a à
peine elle avait 12 ans et grâce aux
actions de l'auto organisation on a
réussi à annuler son mariage là c'est
également l'histoire de cette jeune dame
appelle 20 ans qui à cause des exactions
d un sujet de boko haram a vu l'un de
ses fils égorger ainsi que son époux ou
une salle de ces derniers a été leakée
d'un air et ses cailloux l'a obligé à
l'aube oil egloff aux interventions que
nous avons menés au bout dit n'a laissé
personne n'a plus le plein au goût à la
vie le chef de l'état a annoncé que la
france allait consacrer 120 millions
d'euros à un fonds pour soutenir la
lutte contre les violences et les
discriminations faites aux femmes dans
le monde
et s'est exprimé aussi sur la situation
des femmes en france pour emmanuel
macron là aussi il reste beaucoup à
faire
et pourtant en france aujourd'hui il y a
encore tenté tant à faire il dit encore
et l'actualité récente l'a montré le
pire de ces violences qui s'exerce dans
notre pays
est ce la loi qui est là à changer à
nouveau nom ce sont des habitudes des
silences des dysfonctionnements profond
mais qui derrière conduisent au
féminicide au pire il n'y aura plus de
silence plus de passe-droit plus
d'habitude
à l'occasion de cette journée un concert
de klaxon était organisée aujourd'hui
par amnistie internationale a devant
l'ambassade d'arabie saoudite à paris en
solidarité avec les saoudiennes qui se
sont battus pour pouvoir conduire des
militants de lo ong réclament par
ailleurs la libération de loudes gêne à
la toule mnh fans
aziz al youssef trois défenseurs des
droits des femmes
arrêté en mai 2018 un objectif de ce
concert de klaxon alertés et interpeller
les autorités saoudiennes
l'objectif c'était de faire du bruit ici
devant l'ambassade d'arabie saoudite
pour interpeller les autorités
saoudiennes et leur demandait de libérer
les militantes les défenseurs des droits
humains qui sont injustement emprisonnés
simplement parce qu'elles ont demandé
leur droit à conduire et parce qu'elles
ont dénoncé le système de tutelle
masculine répressif à l'égard des femmes
dans le pays
revenons à l'assemblée nationale cette
semaine deux femmes vice président de
l'assemblée ont piloté au palais bourbon
les questions gouvernement en prévision
de la journée internationale des droits
des femmes aujourd'hui un sous les
applaudissements la vice présidente
annie genevard a ouvert la séance mardi
en remerciant pour son initiative le
président de l'assemblée à richard
ferrand à l'origine de ce changement de
fauteuils mais vous allez le voir
en réponse à une question d'un député à
celle qui préside la séance va donner la
parole au ministre de l'intérieur qui y
fait une gaffe
la parole est à monsieur christophe
castaner ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur madame la présidente
c'est madame la présidente c'est pas si
compliqué que ça et bis repetita
il ya un an c'était la ministre de la
santé agnès buzyn qui avait laissé
échapper un monsieur le président alors
qu annie genevard encore elle se
trouvait déjà au perchoir
les vieilles habitudes pourtant cette
assemblée est la plus féminisée de la
vème république elle compte 230 femmes
pour 347 hommes
mercredi c'était la seule autre vice
président de l'assemblée carole bureau
bonnart de la république en marche qui a
présidé les traditionnelles questions au
gouvernement un sous les
applaudissements aussi mes gros dilemme
ce jour-là à la question d'une députée
sur la ruralité à celle qui préside la
séance hésitant elle hésite pour la
réponse doit elle donner la parole à un
ministre ou à une ministre
regardez à quand un véritable plan
marshall pour la ruralité
merci merci madame la députée la parole
est un madame jacqueline gourault
ministre de la
non monsieur d'hermann en vad madame
viens donc la parole est hamas s'il vous
plaît cher collègue madame brad madame
jacqueline gourault ministre de la
cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
ouf c'est une ministre à qui prend la
parole jacqueline gourault l'honneur est
sauf
sauf que la ministre à son tour faire
une gaffe
[Applaudissements]
madame la sénatrice mme à la baisse des
prix
[Applaudissements]
je suis désolé ce que les zones et la
députée
et que tu les avais raison aïe aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe aïe sénatrice à l'assemblée
nationale jacqueline à les gaffes 1 dans
ce domaine pour sûr hommes et femmes
on est tous égaux allez on termine par
le dessin du jour le coup d'oeil de man
dans le midi libre il vaut le coup
d'oeil se dresse à regarder des patrons
à une salariée
vous préférez qu'on dise madame
l'ingénieur e ou l'ingénieuse juste le
même salaire que monsieur l'ingénieur ça
ira voilà il vous myriam être le même
pour le même boulot vous gagnez plus ou
moins qu'un cas david pujadas bruce
toussaint ou ici à levie question pour
une championne un jeu les lions je vous
laisse deviner
je suis sûr que vous avez deviné très
bien tout seul j'adore ce dessin merci
merci beaucoup ahmed on en vient à notre
débat transition toute trouvée à
compétence égale salaire égal ce serait
si simple si les entreprises respectait
la loi
seulement voilà il faut les contraindre
en matière d'égalité professionnelle
c'est la conclusion à laquelle sont
parvenus muriel pénicaud malienne de
chiapa et la majorité vraiment les
contraintes c'est en tous les cas la
philosophie de ce nouvel index d'égalité
obligatoire dans les entreprises de plus
de 1000 salariés
un système que nous les tailles mari la
bat à compétence et poster go
l'écart salarial entre femmes et hommes
est aujourd'hui de 9 % pour combler cet
écart
le gouvernement a donc mis en place ce
qu'il appelle un index de l'égalité
calculé sur la base de cinq indicateurs
l'écart de rémunération entre hommes et
femmes bien sûr mais aussi le taux
d'augmentation individuelle
le taux de promotion le pourcentage de
salariés ayant bénéficié d'augmentations
dans l'année du retour de congé
maternité et la parité parmi les dix
plus hautes rémunérations de
l'entreprise
la note finale était à bille sur 100
points les entreprises de 250 à 1000
salariés ont jusqu'au 1er septembre
prochain pour réaliser cet index
quant à celle de 50 à 250 salariés
elles devront satisfaire à cette
obligation avant le 1er mars 2020 si
leur score n'atteint pas 75 elles auront
alors trois ans pour se conformer à la
législation sous peine d'être sanctionné
à hauteur de
1% de leur masse salariale alors on a
les premiers chiffres un des bons et
comportements des moins bons
marie-pierre x1 sur 1400 entreprises
seules 800 ont publié leur index c'est à
peine plus de la moitié comment vous
l'expliquez d'abord c'est insuffisant
c'est des entreprises trouver ce qu'ils
n'ont pas répondu à leurs obligations
c'est un manquement à la loi donc il va
falloir qu'elle y répondrait le pénicaud
a expliqué qu'elle devait y répondre la
dans les jours qui allait arriver sinon
en effet et bien les services de l'état
les contraindrait à publier ses chiffres
quelle façon précisément et bien
j'imagine à travers des contrôles
d'urssaf à travers des autres
collections de travail l'inspection du
travail et avec les services de l'état
qui leur demanderait de merde vous êtes
sûrs et laisse par ces chiffres la
moitié jouent le jeu la loi vient d'être
promulguée premier 1er mars
bah ça veut dire surtout que les
entreprises fassent du mal à satisfaire
un besoin de transparence et il va
falloir qu'elle qu'elle s'y soumettent
s'éteint c'est un voeu à la fois delà de
la population mais également des acteurs
publics et il faut que les entreprises
aujourd'hui nous permettent de disposer
de cette photographie dans une zone dont
nous avons toutes et tous besoin pour
pouvoir ensuite regardé les leviers à
mettre en place nathalie margrethe vous
vous l'avez mis en place cette fameuse
fameux d'index de l'égalité est ce que
concrètement on a vu c'est assez
technique
il ya des critères qui joue sur le
salaire mais qui joue aussi sur les
promotions qui joue sur les postes à
haute responsabilité
est-ce qu'il est facile à mettre en
oeuvre comment ça se passe concrètement
celle des âges qui pilote tout oui nous
c'est les équipes rh qui ont fait un
travail formidable et qui ont
effectivement travaillé sur sur cet
index qu'on a publié le 1er mars et on
s'en félicite
il est la mise en oeuvre à partir du
moment où vous avez un bon système
d'information il n'y a pas deux il ya
pas de sujet en tant que tel et je suis
ravi que ce que cette loi soit soit été
publié parce qu'elle est assortie d'une
obligation de résultat et je trouve que
en termes d'image de marque employeur
c'est vraiment fondamental de pouvoir
respecter cette obligation et surtout ça
fait un jalon pour les années à avenir
et les prochains sujets à traiter 1000
trains concrètement c'est pas bizarre
finalement que les entreprises se note
elle-même
alors il ya des critères mais voilà la
rémunération sur les écarts l'entreprise
décide de se donner voilà jusqu'à 40
points et puis on accumule les points et
puis si on a 75 sur 100 est considéré
comme un bon élève et vous il vous
semble
comment dire pertinent cet outil c'est
une pique moi j'ai examiné un petit peu
les premiers résultats qui sont sorties
qui ont été compilées pour les 40
premières entreprises celles du cac 40
est en fait on observe quand même de
très très très bon résultat à bonne
nouvelle alors est ce que c'est vraiment
une bonne nouvelle je ne sais pas où est
ce que celle à l'index qui est calculé
de façon un petit peu avantageuse pour
les entreprises
quand on regarde les entreprises du cac
40 on a des 95 et 98 des 94 on a toutes
les entreprises du cac 40 que des bons
élèves au dessus de 75 serait bon
résultat vous doutez c'est un de ces
chiffres alors c'est important de
comprendre quelle est la méthodologie en
rentrant de minutes dans le détail les
illusions et de l'index qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui il ya les premiers
résultats sont très bons et en fait le
problème c'est un problème c'est que
c'est ça vous ça vaut auto satisfaction
générale de la part de beaucoup
d'entreprises j'ai vu encore un titre en
challenger aujourd'hui qu'ils étaient
les champions de l'égalité parmi les
entreprises françaises ça va permettre
une auto satisfaction parce que je pense
que ce que cet index est assez généreux
dans l'octroi de deux points alors je
vous prends je vous prends les deux
exemples très concrets
premièrement le premier pour 40 points
c'est-à-dire pour 40% de la note
il y a les écarts de rémunération
abstenu le premier critère voilà le
premier critère les écarts de
rémunération sont calculés à poste à
niveau équivalent et à âge équivalent
c'est à dire que c'est une photo qui est
statique qui va faire comme vous l'avez
dit très bien dans votre reportage le
focus sur les écarts de salaires
un même poste pour un même poste on a
aujourd'hui 9 % d'écart de salaire
sauf que cela semble finalement très
très peu ce sont 2 9 % d'écart salarial
en france on se dit ça reste et les
riantes ce serait ça c'est la questure
l'intégralité des inégalités et
l'intégralité des inégalités tous
métiers confondus tout contrat de
travail confondus en prenant en compte
les tentes par les temps partiels
contraints les différences de métier
également et pas à simplement à poste
équivalent sur un équivalent temps plein
on arrive à 27%
donc ce premier critère par exemple sur
40 points va vraiment se focaliser sur
les écarts à poste équivalent il va
s'attaquer qu'à une petite partie du
problème
autre exemple je prends par exemple
deuxième critère le deuxième critère
c'est la fréquence des augmentations de
salaires dans notre île
notée sur 20 points sur 20 points c'est
important quand même 20 points et là on
a non pas le montant des augmentations
comparer entre les femmes et les hommes
qui pourrait donner une une
une idée du rattrapage que qu'opèrent
les rh au sein des entreprises
mais le pourcentage de femmes c'est à
dire que pratiquement parlant si vous
augmentez deux importants toutes les
femmes
et si vous augmentez de 5% tout ou deux
tous les hommes
vous avez 20 sur 20 ha secrétaire
puisque 100 % des femmes auront été
augmenté et sans pareil les hommes
auront été hautement il faut donner la
parole de la défense comme et je les
congolais nous faire tous les critères
et sûrement du temps à naviguer
rapidement par rapport à la transparence
qui est dommage c'est que le l'index est
publié dans sa globalité sur le critère
sur 100 et on ne sait pas quels sont les
points des différents critères et les
données qui ont été utiles j'aimerais
beaucoup savoir quels sont les montants
des écarts calculé beaucoup de reproches
et que vous arrête à cet index un manque
de transparence sur les différents
critères et comment on fait des notes
ensuite dans le mécano si je puis dire
de chaque critère qu'est ce que vous
pouvez nous dire pour le défendre
il a été négocié par des patrons
partenaires sociaux mais les entreprises
ont réussi au fond à imposer aussi leurs
vues dans la manière de voilà de
l'établir noir sur blanc dans la loi cet
index les entreprises n'ont rien n'y a
pas de gagnant il n'y a pas de perdants
dans l'est dans l'élaboration de cet
index les gagnants ce sont les femmes
pour lesquelles on doit aujourd'hui il
vient travailler pour qu'elle soit mieux
rémunéré et magna
de manière égale avec les hommes donc ça
des gagnants de ce soit ce sont elles
sont les femmes
en revanche les entreprises
effectivement on le voit bien d'ailleurs
elles sont encore frileuses pour oublier
cet index donc ça prouve bien que malgré
tous atteints dès que ce n'est pas non
plus une publicité gratuite pour toutes
les entreprises dans leur manière de
travailler sur l'égalité professionnelle
elle dans le mode de calcul en fait dans
les roches qui sont faites dans le val
de gray leur notamment sur moi je la
rémunération ou les augmentations je
vous trouve dur parce qu'en fait c'est
césar c'est l'élément pardon notamment
quand on prend par exemple le retour du
congé maternité est bien quand on
regarde l'index est à 27 % aujourd'hui
des entreprises qui ne satisfont pas
leurs obligations légales d'augmenter sa
femme à leur retour de congé mais alors
expliquez nous parce qu'il faut
s'arrêter sur ce congé maternité
oui beaucoup de femmes ou fait
expérience d'un congé maternité avec
évidemment aucune augmentation à la clé
pendant la période d'absence pendant le
congé maternité
parfois même ce sont les postes qui ne
sont plus au rendez vous au retour ça
c'est totalement illégal
que dit ce critère vous devez suivre
l'évolution des augmentations de
salaires le même quand vous n'êtes pas
là le critère dit que vous devez
satisfaire les obligations légales de la
loi de 2006 qui dit que lorsqu'il ya eu
un mouvement d'augmentation
madame pourra nous l'expliqué plus
précisément plus précisément en matière
de rh mais lorsqu'il ya eu des
mouvements d'augmentation dans une
entreprise est bien une femme qui
revient d'un congé maternité son congé
maternité n'a pas à la sanctionner dans
l'octroi de cette de cette augmentation
or manifestement il ya une partie des
d'entreprise aujourd'hui qu'ils ne
satisfont pas cette obligation légale et
là par exemple ça fait partie des sujets
sur lesquels elles vont devoir rectifier
le tir de la même manière qu'on voit
bien que l'octroi également des
meilleures rémunérations des femmes
bien évidemment est largement
insuffisant je crois qu'il ya à peu près
deux femmes sur dix qui bénéficient des
meilleurs des meilleurs
c'est le dernier verre c'est d'être prêt
doit au moins quatre femmes parmi ces
dit plus haut
revoilà en moyenne jouer le salaire on
se demandait d'ailleurs pourquoi pas 5
au moins la parité c'est 4 sur 10
nathalie nathalie margrethe c'est une
révolution dans les entreprises que de
se conformer à ce genre de critères je
trouve que c'est très important
effectivement peut-être que le calcul
n'est et compliqué pour certaines
entreprises enfin je vois pas où est la
difficulté
peut-être que la location des points
n'est pas n'est pas satisfaisante mais
en tout cas ça elle mérite de d'exister
et est ce que je trouve important c'est
c'est la dynamique nous aujourd'hui on a
un index de 87 sur sur 100 je considère
que c'est encourageant mais c'est pas
assez pas satisfaisant et il faut
mesurer cet index dans dans le temps est
ce qu'on est en train de d'analysé c'est
effectivement les critères pourquoi
effectivement sur sur certains critères
on est on est moins bron est on est on
met en place le plan d'action en face
vous seriez prête vous à ce que votre
entreprise figure dans une liste qu'ils
soient publics de façon claire dans la
presse sur un site dédié là si je
comprends bien chaque entreprise publie
sa note et ses différents modes de
calcul en fonction des cinq critères
mais il faut aller chercher entreprise
par entreprise pour connaître les bons
et les mauvais élèves c'est pas du name
and shame ça c'est du voilà une manière
de contraintes mais en deçà de ce que
font les anglo saxons
oui on serait prêts nous être sûrs sur
une liste est d'ailleurs quand quand on
voit les on est nous mêmes allés voir
les notes des de nos confrères et
d'autres d'autres entreprises pour
savoir comment on se positionner les
timides ses lignes fixes est cette loi
il aurait fallu avoir des listes claires
très timide dans le sens où comme l'a
très bien dit mais americ sein par
exemple le critère sur le congé
maternité déjà dans la loi en fait il
existait déjà et les lilas
mais on voit bien qu'à l'aller web
professionnel n'est pas la loi pour
rappeler comme le contexte historique la
première loi sur l'égalité salariale cés
1972 ensuite à une grande loi avec
l'introduction du rapport de situation
comparée
on parle de 1981 avec kid est yvette
roudy donc des outils on en a eu des on
en a eu plein et en particulier il faut
rappeler aussi que les différentes lois
travail consécutives ont détruit c'est
pas la première fois qu'ils aient pas
appliquer réellement sur le terrain
on arrive aussi avec les entreprises il
ya un accord qui a été signé c'est
peut-être c'est la bonne méthode mes
parents dans dans la dent les
successives au travail on a détricoté un
certain nombre de contraintes qui était
faite aux entreprises en termes de
production de rapport de situation
comparée et d'obligation de négociations
avec les syndicats sur lequel est le
plan à mettre en oeuvre pour réduire les
inégalités salariales
donc je salue toute initiative mais je
suis à peu près cent pour cent sûr que
quand on voit les les notes des
entreprises du cac 40 qui qui sont
toutes au dessus de 75
ça ne peut aboutir a finalement que une
auto satisfait ni auto satisfaction et
beaucoup d'indications auprès de la part
des entreprises qui pour certaines
sont régulièrement attaqués en justice
pour des cas de discrimination sexuelle
des cas de harcèlement au travail des
cas de discriminations liées à la
grossesse donc ça c'est à la réalité des
femmes sur le terrain en fait et cette
dissonance entre cette hausse haute otis
auto satisfaction générale des
entreprises qui va déboucher de ce cet
index où tout le monde à 80 ou 90% qui
est la réalité sur le terrain
quand on parle par exemple de la
question des violences au travail par
exemple ce qui est exclu de cet index
ces problématiques on peut pas imaginer
que la carrière des femmes ne soient pas
entravés par les cas de harcèlement on
dit on
je rappellerai juste les chiffres une
femme sur cinq connaîtra des violences
au travail
au cours de sa carrière bien sûr que ça
a un impact on aurait pu parler
conciliation vie privée vie
professionnelle c'est un tout ça pour
dire que c'est un sujet extrêmement
complexe avec de multiples leviers et
que vraiment il faut s'attaquer aux 27 %
des inégalités salariales et non pas
simplement aux 9 % à poste alors qu'ivan
ans et âge équivalent et ça c'est
extrêmement important pour comprendre la
complexité d'une entend dégager un vos
critiques ce soir on va voir si elles
sont partagées
peut-être par une partie de l'opposition
sûrement et qu'en disent les auteurs de
la loi
muriel pénicaud marlène schiappa on peut
pas faire encore un vrai bilan mais tout
de même
depuis le 1er mars créé ce passe t'il et
qu'en pense-t-elle écoutez c'était il ya
un an
emmanuel macron avait promis le name and
shame pour les entreprises qui ne
respectait pas l'égalité hommes femmes
la stigmatisation pour changer les
comportements expliquait-il un an plus
tard
la musique est un peu différente je ne
crois pas que la dénonciation suffisent
si le name and shame ça suffisait on
aurait déjà changé le monde
là on fait quelque chose de plus
puissant ont fait une évaluation
objective
une mesure du progrès une transparence
et une mobilisation des acteurs plus
question de donner le nom des
entreprises mauvaises élèves
plus question non plus d'obtenir leur
classement sur internet
le gouvernement mise plutôt sur le long
terme
on passe d'une obligation de moyens à
une obligation de résultat et le
gouvernement a donné trois ans aux
entreprises qui ont des écarts de
salaires entre les femmes et les
pour les résorber sous peine évidemment
de pénalités financières importantes des
propos difficilement compréhensible pour
l'opposition
si le ministère du travail faisait son
travail jusqu'au bout en tout cas la
ministre elle ferait une synthèse sur
son site internet et chacun pourra aller
voir ce qu'il en est des entreprises est
de savoir comment les unes et les autres
se classe s'il faut que vous alliez sur
le site de plus de 1000 entreprises pour
trouver le résultat d'un decs personne
va le faire d'autant qu'à la date limite
du 1er mars
seule la moitié des entreprises avaient
répondu à l'obligation légale de publier
leur index et pierrick sein c'est un peu
le jeu on est là pour aller faire un peu
l'avocat du diable et les critiques sont
là qu'est ce que vous répondez au fond
c'est en deçà des attentes allez faire
la liste une liste claire sur le site du
ministère là c'est vrai qu'un mâle en
chercher entreprise par entreprise
l'incitation à respecter la loi et est
moindre moi ce que je crois c'est qu'il
faut regarder quel est l'objectif de
tout ça l'objectif de tout cela c'est de
faire en sorte que les femmes à swaps et
aux tempes les hommes donc on vous dit
par exemple qu'il faut s'attaquer
pas uniquement aux 9 % résiduelles un
peu inexplicable mais également à
l'ensemble des inégalités de revenu je
suis d'accord avec vous c'est le cas
avec les critères par exemple sur la
question du congé maternité
on n'en auront là on l'a on le prend en
considération la lidc bien qu'il ya
d'autres textes qui permettent de
s'attaquer de manière générale allait
aux inégalités de revenus la bière qui
est bien c'est légal et d'inégalité de
salaire on menait même succès mais
vraiment l'un des procédés apprécié et
même promu par emmanuel macron dans la
campagne
pourquoi elle n'est pas allée jusqu'au
bout est ce que c'est la négociation qui
a buté là dessus pourquoi finalement le
gouvernement a renoncé à les couvrir de
honte comme on dit en publiant des
listes claires marche très bien en moi
je veux bien qu'on me pose la question
aux côtés de mauvaises idées moi je n'ai
rien contre le name and shame peut être
utile d'ailleurs marlène schiappa
l'avait également fait l'année dernière
et c'est très utile mais là si on va
aller jusqu'au bout de la démarche et
résorber ces 9 % est ce que une fois
qu'on a dit qu'il y avait et elle est l
entreprise qui ne respectait pas ses
obligations légales quid après très bien
donc ça va faire la une des médias
pendant une semaine d'action ça compte
eh bien c'est la réputation
en revanche aujourd'hui l'index permet
et bien comme vous le disiez madame de
créer des marques de d'entreprise qui
fait que déjà il ya des entreprises qui
se sentent pénalisés par rapport à
d'autres et qui vont peut-être moins
bien recruté et vont avoir des talents
peut être moins intéressant pour elle et
au delà du grand public et ces règles
c'est important vous avez raison mais ce
qui est important aussi pour une
entreprise c'est de recruter des talents
qu'ils soient performants et puis il ya
également la question de la clientèle le
dans la clientèle a priori elle est
composée de femmes et d'hommes et pour
une entreprise c'est jamais très bon
d'avoir de très mauvaises notes à
l'égard de sa clientèle féminine
donc finalement il jouit entrepris les
cours pratiques associées d'autres
cabinets de conseil ça suffit pour à
exercer une pression ce système d'index
de notation est ce que vous allez vous
garder les notes entre vous est ce que
pense que vous allez recruter aussi là
je pense que c'est une vraie donnée pour
pour les jeunes talents qu'on qu'on
embauche on nous interroge de plus en
plus sur notre notre politique en termes
de diversity notre politique en termes
de de mixité et je suis quasiment
certaine que les candidats et on est
dans une période où les ressources sont
rares vont regarder les les index en
tout cas sur sur notre métier comment ça
se passe à l'étranger
les anglo saxons beaucoup plus loin que
dit votre étude que vous avez réalisés
sur les femmes puissantes comme on dit
maintenant vous menez une business dans
plus de 35 pays
c'est vrai que je pense que les pays
anglo saxons ont été plus influencé que
nous par le le mythe ou mais d'une
manière générale
alors ça c'est intéressant il ya un
effet mis tout sur l'égalité
professionnelle dans les entreprises sur
les salaires sur les promotions ou je
pense qu'à une vraie prise de conscience
qu'il y ait au mouvement mis tout est
dit d'ailleurs les résultats de notre
étude 2019
je pense est également porté par parce
par ce mouvement parce qu on observe
aujourd'hui notre étude porte sur a été
réalisée auprès de 5000 chef
d'entreprise personnes dirigeante cadres
de direction dans 135 pays et on voit
une progression du nombre de femmes qui
occupent des postes de direction on a eu
une progression de 2,5 points est
aujourd'hui un peu de direction sur
quatre dans le cadre de notre étude et
est occupé par une femme ce que je
trouve plutôt encourageant encourageant
ça reste évidemment loin de la parité
il ya un effet mis tout balances ton
port il ya un effet sur l'explosion
planétaire du phénomène des agressions
sexuelles sur ces questions qui a priori
sont très distinctes l'égalité
professionnelle je pense qu'il ya une
prise de conscience du grand public des
femmes et des jeunes femmes clientes
dans le monde du travail qui fait que la
tolérance au sexisme elle s'abaisse et
donc les comportements sexistes qui
entravent la carrière des femmes puisque
comme on l'expliquait tout à l'heure le
sujet extrêmement complexe un
comportement sexiste quand on gagne
moins d'argent moins de rémunération à
compétence égale je pose la question où
ils ont mené dans le sexisme mais le
sexisme alimente aussi les inégalités
salariales prenant l'exemple dont on a
parlé récemment de la ligue du lol sur
les journalistes
on voit bien que cette stratégie de
harcèlement sexiste dans le milieu
journalistique a abouti à une promotion
d'hommes qui qui étaient les arts seiler
et puis souvent une rune un retrait
certaines sont quittés twitter alors que
pour elle c'est en tant que journaliste
était extrêmement important donc on peut
pas faire l'impasse soit aussi la
question des violences et du sexisme à
l'intérieur des entreprises si on veut
lutter efficacement contre les
inégalités en termes de deir on se dira
que cette ce phénomène mondial du mythe
ou peut-être même plus efficace qu'une
nouvelle loi ou qu'un accord entreprises
patronat salariés en matière d'égalité
professionnelle c'est un peu audacieux
de dire ça oui il ya j'ai préféré je
pense que l'accord il était nécessaire
je pense que là cette nouvelle loi était
nécessaire parce que ça va permettre
également des discussions à l'inter des
entreprises va falloir que les manades
j'ai recensé 10 il va peut-être y avoir
des bonus pour les managers qui vont
davantage prendre en considération la
promotion de leurs talents féminins
donc ça c'est important et puis il faut
aussi en effet vous le disiez que les
syndicats s'en saisisse moi j'appelle
également les syndicats à se saisir de
cette qu'alors d'égalité comment
peuvent-ils le faire de façon très
concrète est ce qu ils peuvent suivre
l'évolution de ces notations pousser les
entreprises à remplir cet index
les trois ans par exemple c'est long
pour se mettre en conformité
alors avec cet index est ce qu'on
pourrait revenir là dessus et faire un
temps plus court les trois mois soit
qu'ils étaient nés je pense qu'ils
étaient ils sont nécessaires si on a des
entreprises qui ont des retards
considérables
il faut par des entreprises qui sont en
dessous de 75 ans il faut leur dire s'il
a la possibilité de le faire
par ailleurs là on parle beaucoup des
grandes entreprises et c'est très
important parce que c'est l'actualité
il faut avoir en tête également que en
novembre ce seront les petites
entreprises qui vont devoir également
remplir ses obligations c'est qu'il y
aura une dynamique est absolument et ce
qui n'était pas jusqu'à présent ne
portait pas beaucoup toujours d'une
attention sur ces petites entreprises
qui en fait sont les plus gros
recruteurs dans notre pays c'est vrai
vous parlez d entrée du cac 40 c'est
très important est peut-être qu'en effet
il y a des notes qui sont pas si
mauvaises pour ces entreprises parce que
il ya des services de rh comme madame et
qui ont fait procéder éléments la soie
lacé éléments qui ont en considération
mais les petites entreprises qui
aujourd'hui n'ont pas forcément ces
éléments en tête quelles que soient les
secteurs professionnels d'ailleurs vont
devoir les mettre en place donc je crois
que l'apport de la loi il est aussi à ce
titre là c'est les peu de les grosses
truites mais également les tpe vous
pouvez me citer une femme à la tête du
cac 40 en france
et bien madame kouchner que chez
rebeller pas exactement p dg dale jr n'a
pas c'est quelque chose quand même pas
de pdg niveau vraiment de la direction
du top organisateurs
il ya des femmes dirigeantes en france
mais quand on regarde le cas carotte il
y en a pas la question des causes
elle se pose qu'est ce qui se passe est
ce que les femmes ne s'autorise pas est
ce que les hommes leur empêche et ce
alors c'est la société
alors j'aimerai quand on regarde les
comités directeurs des grandes
entreprises on voit souvent que les
femmes se sont cantonnés encore
aujourd'hui à des à des postes présumé
féminin direction des ressources
humaines directrice de la communication
qui ne permettent pas souvent de devenir
ensuite responsable de l'entreprise
et puis j'entends beaucoup de choses qui
sont dites effectivement c'est important
le nombre de femmes dans le top 10 des
remue rémunération le temps le mais je
pense qu'il faut aussi voir ce combat
féminin oui ça a un effet de symbole
mais en fait aujourd'hui quand on parle
des inégalités salariales aujourd'hui il
faut voir que l'essentiel des inégalités
salariales elles se passent pour madame
tout le monde je dirais et c'est ça veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui par an 4 important
d'aider des contrats à temps partiel
sont souvent contraints sont des emplois
féminins que 70% des smicards sont des
smicarde donc en fait les travailleurs
pauvres les travailleurs les travailleur
au smic sont des femmes
en fait et c'est à elle en fait qu'il
faudrait aussi s'adresser je pense que
c'est important de le rappeler parce que
c'est la journée de lutte pour les
droits des femmes et de toutes les
femmes aujourd'hui
et en terme de on a vu aussi beaucoup de
maires de mères isolées qui ont des
petits salaires des temps partiels des
semis kdd smic et des difficultés à
finir les fins de mois et pour qui cet
index qui parle de rémunération du top
10 ne va pas leur le nombre de femmes
très important voilà dans le mouvement
des gilet jaune transition toute trouvée
puisque place de la république depuis
15h40 et bien les militants et
militantes de la cause des femmes qui se
sont rassemblés ont choisi cet horaire
15h40
l'horaire symbolique qui signifie que
près 15h40 les femmes travaillent
gratuitement nathalie gilbert a suivi ce
rassemblement elle est aux côtés de
sophie binet qui est en charge des
questions égalité femmes-hommes
pour la cgt on va écouter son entretien
cette mobilisation est organisée à
l'appel de nombreuses associations mais
aussi de syndicats dont le vôtre sophie
binet pourquoi êtes vous mobiliser
aujourd'hui alors la cgt appelle les
femmes à arrêter le travail aujourd'hui
à 15h40 pour dire que les 26 % d'écart
de rémunération n'en peut plus que c'est
plus possible qu'ils aient 30% des
femmes qui soient enfermés sur des
emplois à temps partiel avec une
précarité extrêmement importante que
c'est plus possible qu'elle n'ait pas de
déroulement de carrière dès lors que l
on des enfants et qu'elles veulent avoir
des enfants et une parentalité et puis
aussi pour dire stop aux violences
sexistes et sexuelles
donc en fait le mot d'ordre c'est
l'égalité maintenant on n'en peut plus
d'attendre
qu'est ce que vous pensez de l'index
femmes hommes est ce que c'est un ça
peut être efficace grâce à notre
mobilisation l'année dernière nous
avions devons gagner une obligation de
résultat les entreprises sont tenues de
supprimer les écarts de rémunération
c'est une grande victoire
le problème c'est cet outil de mesure où
le lobby patronal a obtenu un outil de
mesure qui permet de neutraliser
l'essentiel des inégalités de salaires
et de l'est opacifier en fait donc
finalement cet index il doit être revu
pour garantir la transparence et puis
pour dans ces critères ne plus
neutraliser les écarts de rémunération
mais au contraire permettent de les
identifier pour qu'on puisse les
supprimer alors dans cet index on ne
pointe pas les modes et les mauvais
élèves
est-ce que du coup c'est assez
contraignant pour vous non c'est n'être
pas assez contraignant parce que les
inspections du travail n'ont pas les
moyens de contrôler l'index parce que il
n'ya pas de transparence organisée en
directions des organisations syndicales
et des salariés pour le vérifier et
qu'en fait c'est un peu les employeurs
qui s'attribue eux mêmes leurs notes sur
la base des critères bien sûr et donc on
n'a pas de fiabilité aujourd'hui de
l'index avec des résultats qui sont
assez étonnants en fonction des
entreprises donc il faut d'urgence
revoir cet index pour en faire un vrai
outil de mesure des inégalités de
salariale et ainsi garantir la mise en
oeuvre de la loi qui a été votée l'année
dernière et qui encore une fois est vidé
de son contenu à cause du lobby patronal
qui refusent d'augmenter les salaires
des femmes
merci sophie binet d'avoir répondu à nos
questions voilà c'est un peu le jeu d
opposition n'est pas surpris par la
position de la cgt mais là encore il ya
un certain nombre d'arguments soul
si je puis me permettre on n'a pas
beaucoup parlé de la question des
contrôles qui va contrôler comment et
avec quelle fréquence ces notations le
fait que voilà faut quand même faire
confiance aux entreprises il ya des
critères mais il faut contrôler sur
l'application correcte de ce qui est
prévu dans la loi donc sera notamment
l'inspection du travail qui va vérifier
la réalisation de l'index qui va
également regarder très précisément
quels sont les laits carsalade dans les
entreprises est en effet des entreprises
qui n'auront pas satisfait à leur obéir
à des contrôles inopinés l'inspection
des boules
oui je pense qu'il y aura des côtes et
des contrôles inopinés je pense que les
mots les modalités sont fixées par
muriel pénicaud et le ministère du
travail
mais ces obligations doivent être
respectés donc en effet moi je suis pour
qu'il y ait des contrôles et qu'ensuite
et bien les entreprises est bien
respecté la loi
elles devront le temps nécessaire pour
le coup on est d'accord pour pouvoir
résorber les écarts salariaux s'il y en
avait et puis pour qu'enfin nous
puissions avoir cette obligation de
résultat que nous attendons comme vous
le disiez depuis maintenant 1971
nathalie margrethe on entend les doutes
1 il ya beaucoup d'arguments sur la
table qui rendent au fond assez
sceptique sur l'efficacité de cet index
vous qui l'avez mis en place qu'est ce
que vous pouvez dire à tout au fond les
femmes en entreprise qui savent que
voilà elles sont pénalisées
ça va aller mieux vous allez voir ça va
marcher si vous y croyez bien sûr
alors moi j'y crois alors plutôt que de
remettre en cause l'index je pense que
on parlait de transparence enfin on a un
cabinet d'audit et de conseil donc le
dit on connaît donc il faudrait qu
effectivement cet index soit soit
auditée et
et qui et pourquoi pas une communication
non pas globale mais mais en fonction
des différents des différents critères
et nous on est vraiment en train de
travailler sur sur les raisons qui font
qu'on est on n'ait pas obtenu la note la
note maximale et c'est là où en fait
l'index c'est un diagnostic mais il doit
s'inscrire dans un plan pluriannuel et
on met en place d d d d action / / sur
le sujet et je pense que demain si on
continue à lutter également contre les
stéréotypes qu'on arrive également à
conserver nos talents féminins on va
créer un vivier de personnes qui
pourront augmenter l esthétique vous
aurez le mot de la fin c'est mieux que
rien tout de même ça c'est une évidence
non on a eu beaucoup rien pendant très
longtemps ou s'il ya donc on aimerait
aussi avoir une égalité réelle et je
pense que les jeunes générations
aujourd'hui sont extrêmement demandeuses
d'égalité et il faudrait vraiment que ce
soit une résorption effective et
aujourd'hui l'index tel qu'il est
construit aujourd'hui j'ai un peu peur
que ça fasse beaucoup de communication
de la part des entreprises bon eh bien
c'est dit on aller pour les contres les
doutes et les avocats de ce nouvel outil
merci à toutes les trois d'être venu sur
lcp
pour ce débat dans un instant on va
ouvrir à notre page spéciale consacrée
au grand débat national ça fait le débat
vous savez elle s'est désormais tous les
vendredis le magazine hebdo dès le cp au
coeur de toutes ses réunions citoyennes
mais d'abord ce témoignage en ce 8 mars
journée de la femme elle ne serait pas
devenu député
si elle n'avait pas écouté au fond les
hommes
ici elle n'avait écouté que la branche
féminine de sa famille un autre exemple
de cette forme d'autocensure où les
femmes peinent à s'autoriser à prendre
le pouvoir elle s'appelle sophie auconie
elle est élue elle rm à l'assemblée elle
a raconté cet épisode à mario lefebvre
et moi et moi
extraits vous savez quand il m'a été
demandé de d'être candidate aux
européennes en 2009 donc nous étions en
2008 c'était compliqué pour moi parce
que j'avais des enfants en bas âge et
pour le coup je ne voyais pas comment
comment est ce que je pouvais associé
cette vie
elle d'un député européen souvent partie
et donc j'ai organisé un déjeuner
dominical avec mon papa ma maman mais
mon beau père ma belle mère mes enfants
mon mari
et puis mon p'tit louis qui était tout
petit et à l'époque et laisser le temps
je pense à a fait une urne dans une
boîte à chaussures et puis des petits
papiers blancs et chacun a voté pour ou
contre
alors il y avait un pur qui s'écrivait
per donc j'ai imaginé que c'était oui
plus que ma belle-mère mai et puis dans
la boîte il y avait 2 contre et le reste
était pour qu'ils étaient contre à votre
avis ma mère et ma belle-mère
c est les deux seules femmes de
l'assemblée était contre un engagement
politique d'une femme elle estimait que
la place des femmes n'était pas en
politique
en tout cas pas la mienne elle me disait
alors
l'une et l'autre n'avaient pas forcément
la même analyse ma mère disait tu sais
tu vas souffrir ce qui est vrai ça va
être un engagement compliqué de en
termes de compatibilité avec ta vie de
femme avec ta vie de maman et puis ma
belle-mère c'était plus c'est pas le
rôle de mon fils de prendre la place de
papa poule à la maison parce qu'il est
mon mari est obligé de démissionner
c'est là que j'ai décidé de faire un
combat est un combat d'avoir une
démarche pour casser ce fameux plafond
de verre
mais le cas c'est dans la tête des
femmes c'est à dire qu'elle ne
s'interdisent rien allez ça fait le
débat comme promis c'est parti et c'est
maintenant
[Musique]
bonsoir ali bonsoir mais réaliste
rougerie c'est vous qui piloté cette
semaine ce nouveau numéro et vous avez
choisi de nous montrer deux débats pour
le moins différent ce soir où nous
emmener vous alors on va plonger dans
les quartiers nord de la ville de
marseille il y a déjà eu une quinzaine
de débats à là bas celui qui a attiré
notre attention est organisé par l'imam
d'une mosquée il a voulu tout simplement
mobiliser la population musulmane et il
l'a dit clairement alors on va voir si
ça a marché dans le reportage ce sera
juste après une première étape
un débat à malakoff bastions communistes
dans le sud de paris
alors c'est un ce n'est pas un grand
débat c'est un débat vous allez
comprendre la nuance elle vient de
l'organisatrice qui a voulu se démarquer
les explications eh bien on va découvrir
tout ça tout de suite c'est votre grand
format qui nous plonge donc pour
commencer dans cette banlieue aussi
rouge que bobo j'ai nommé malakoff dans
les hauts-de-seine les images sont
signés juan charest aurélien barrau
maxime rioux au montage regarde
[Musique]
de l'autre côté du périphérique parisien
malakoff bastion communiste depuis 1925
la ville affiche son débat sur les
panneaux publics et dans les boîtes aux
lettres de ces trente mille habitants
ils ont reçu cette invitation à débattre
rendez vous donné dans cette salle des
fêtes
[Musique]
oui tous bien portants l'organisatrice
accueille les premiers participants
jacqueline belhomme 53 ans maire
communiste de la ville
malgré les apparences sont débat n'est
pas tout à fait comme les autres
pas d'inscription sur le site officiel
du grand débat et pas question pour la
communiste de jouer le jeu du
gouvernement
c'est vrai qu'il n'est pas inscrit dans
le cadre du grand débat national puisque
quand nous avons reçu les dictionnaires
logiciel la structure des débats on a
trouvé ça un peu rigide on trouvait que
c'était quand même très orienté sur la
fiscalité par exemple et citoyens me
lève malakoff met souvent en avant alors
établissement un visage mais d'emblée on
nous a dit folco en parler là on s'est
dit que c'était carrément que possible
et qu'on n'avait pas abordé les choses
comme ça c'était pas d'abonnement ce
rêve
si emmanuel macron a semblé fermer la
porte à un rétablissement de l'isf il
n'a jamais été interdit d'en débattre
ici comme ailleurs les participants s'en
prennent aux grandes fortunes
les vrais riches il s'appelle bernard
arnault il s'appelle lagardère il
s'appelle bolloré il s'appelle dry
il s'appelle dassault etc
et c'est là que réside la vraie fortune
c'est pas c'est pas les ministres
qu'est-ce que ça fera si on les ramène à
dix mille à dix mille euros par mois je
voulais simplement répondre à cette
proposition de limitation des hauts
revenus il nous semble que c'est
effectivement nécessaire la part des
très très hauts revenus est en train de
progresser de façon très très importante
par rapport à la richesse nationale
autres thèmes de prédilection la défense
des services publics
il n'y a plus de possibilités d'accès
pour un certain nombre de citoyens aux
services publics parce qu'ils ont fermé
ils ont plus personne à s'adresser
ils n'ont pas d'ordinateur ils sont dans
la fracture numérique et caetera et ils
sont exclus du service public
il faut inverser les choses inverser ce
rapport cette réflexion qu'on doit avoir
sur les ervices celui qui devait pas
être un coût mais un investissement pour
le vire en commun dans cette société
merci il faut renationaliser les
services publics que l'énergie de l'eau
de l'eau des transports on attend
détruit la sncf et après on dit regarder
comme ça marche mal il faut privatiser
tout ça et les hôpitaux les gens se
suicident encore la semaine dernière un
praticien s'est suicidé les infirmières
quittent les hôpitaux ou d'une dizaine
d'années de fonction donc c'est une
véritable catastrophe
merci les gilet jaune des doléances qui
résonne agréablement aux oreilles de la
maire communiste
mais pour certains dans l'assistance
elle n'est pas forcément la meilleure
interlocutrice c'est qu'un autre député
il ya peut-être des gens dans cette
salle qui ont voté pour elle peut-être
certainement sans sais rien l effet
présentés en grand débat à montrouge
lundi la semaine d'avant quand elle
n'est même pas capable de venir sur le
mark
je sais pas si elle a été invitée je ne
sais pas alors maintenant mais même
malade c'est notre député cdh autres
députés de bêtes là elle devrait être la
députée c'est elle lauriane rossi elle a
volontairement sécher ce débat aucune
communication a été faite autour de ce
grand débat en revanche des tracts des
tracts très politique je les ai sous les
yeux celui du parti communiste
extrêmement offensif vis-à-vis du
président de la république
et puis celui réalisé par la mairie avec
l'argent du contribuable mais la caution
qui là aussi au lieu d'appeler un débat
profondément citoyens indépendante
pluraliste transparent se veut également
très offensif et ce débat ne réunissait
pas tu te les garanties d'impartialité
et d'indépendance de pluralisme
également posés par la charte du grand
débat national avec sa photo à la une de
l'invitation
la mère a clairement politiser le débat
elle assume ou et allons au bout et
faisons nous entendre parce que vous
avez le renoncement ya rien de pire
l'ariane pire il ya même des gens qui
spéculent sur le renoncement
parce que ceux qui n'ont envie que rien
ne change ça les arrange qu'on renonce
et bien moi je propose ce soir qu'on ne
renonce pas voilà et qu'on a jusqu'au
bout voilà la mer fera remonter le
contenu du débat directement au
gouvernement mais sans passer par le
site internet dédié au grand débat
national
[Musique]
la bbc dans quelques jours sa charge
nous prolongeons le trajet jusqu'aux
quartiers nord de marseille
au coeur des cités populaires
[Musique]
le débat est organisé dans l'un de ces
hangars où siège une association
culturelle berbère dans ce même bâtiment
et est installée la mosquée du quartier
plus grands lieux de culte musulmans de
marseille d'ailleurs l'organisateur du
débat
azzedine à in touch 62 ans n'est autre
que l'imam de cette mosquée lorsqu'on
regarde les débats qui sont organisées
un peu partout en france du moins par le
prisme de la télé on voit pas énormément
de peau un peu basané voilà et je crois
que c'est une erreur je crois que nous
sommes des citoyens comptent tous les
citoyens il faut prendre la parole voilà
les fidèles de la mosquée ont répondu
présent le débat est ouvert à tous de
gilet jaune se mêlent aux habitants du
quartier
bonsoir voila on va vous demander de
vous installer
on va commencer dans quelques minutes
comme souvent dans les débats
l'emploi est au coeur des discussions la
discrimination en plus
le fait que je m'appelle mois m si vous
voulez il va être refusée à tous les
coups j'ai déjà fait j'ai envoyé mon cv
en tant que mohamed un cv en tant qu
olivier olivier a été pris moi
maintenant donc clairement c'est de la
discrimination c'est pas de la
ségrégation c'est complètement différent
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui au niveau de
l'emploi nos quartiers font peur quand
on voit le nombre de deux tués par
balles l'année dernière moi ya des gens
qui m'appellent me disent mais vous êtes
un gears qu'est-ce qui se passe les
jeunes dans les quartiers moi je les
fréquente c'est ma génération on trouve
du boulot on travaille à chronopost ou
amazon ou dans des sociétés comme ça est
ce que c'est ça l'emploi qu'on veut pour
les jeunes non mais pour qui ce qu'ils
trouvent des emplois de cadres des
emplois de qualité il faut les former et
l'éducation
c'est ce qui est problématique commis à
domicile dans le quartier nord et lycées
de qualité il politique est mise en
place sur nos quartiers aujourd'hui et
qui décide de cette politique
aujourd'hui sur nos quartiers où j'ai
l'impression que c'est il ya des droits
il ya des devoirs
les gens font leurs devoirs mais n'ont
aucun droit
on va donner la parole quand même il
était patient donc au député saïd
ahamada qui était là depuis le début de
la soirée et c'est vrai qu'on subit sur
marseille d'ailleurs aussi une
discrimination une ghettoïsation un
apartheid social appartenant faut nommer
les choses telles qu'elles sont qu'on
n'a pas à subir et c'est l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles j'ai décidé de
faire la politique
trois heures de débat et un constat
marquant quatre femmes seulement pour
une quarantaine d'hommes le député tente
une explication
malheureusement les tâches familiales en
commun encore beaucoup trop aux femmes
et on est exactement aux heures où on
s'occupe des enfants de leur bain des
devoirs des repas et donc ça explique à
mon avis en grande partie le fait que
les femmes aient pas été assez présente
ce soir les tâches ménagères justifie
t'elle aussi la faible mobilisation du
quartier la salle restera à moitié vide
voilà donc pour ce reportage grand
format dont vous êtes l'auteur alice
alors c'est frappant de voir comme ça
ces sommes débattre des discriminations
de leurs difficultés dans les quartiers
nord de marseille il faut le dire peu de
monde presque pas de femmes et un élu de
la majorité elles sont étonnants de ces
scènes
c'est vraiment limamou il vous l'avez
entendu qui a voulu libéré la parole
dans cette petite salle juste à côté de
la mosquée alors il ya eu polémique
juste avant le début du débat elle a été
lancée par le sénateur stéphane ravier
il a twitté en tout début d'après midi
le grand débat aura donc lieu dans une
mosquée islamistes qui diffuse des
textes appelant au jihad
il met en garde si des élus s'y rendent
ils se rendront complice du pire
alors ces allégations personne ne les
confirment d'ailleurs les garantes du
grand débat ce sont ceux qui vérifie si
des réunions peuvent se tenir ou pas si
ça va déraper eux n'ont pas du tout été
saisi par la question sur l'asse
question et l'imam très en colère lui a
annoncé qu'il allait porter plainte pour
diffamation
quant aux députés que l'on a entendu
saïd ahamada il n'a pas voulu commenter
il a simplement levé les yeux au ciel et
ça ne s'est pas produite dans une
mosquée mais bien dans une salle à côté
de la mosquée ce débat malakoff en
revanche alors on est là dans la pure
politique
on l'a vu dans ce reportage ce débat
sert un peu de défouloir pour s'en
prendre à la politique d' emmanuel
macron oui vous avez vu l'invitation qui
a été envoyé aux habitants ça
s'apparente à un tract politique en tout
cas dans cette invitation clairement le
président est critiqué on a pu lire
emmanuel macron est à court de solutions
du maquereau bashing aussi pendant tout
le débat
est-ce que c'était en fait le rendez
vous de l'opposition de gauche avec la
maire communiste et son entourage
et on a aussi vu dans la salle quelques
militants la france insoumise
on va ouvrir notre compteur de la
semaine il est temps où est-ce qu'on en
est du nombre de réunions publiques dans
le tout le pays et surtout du nombre de
contributions
près d'un million et demi de contribuer
son vous allez voir le compteur qui
s'affiche et près de 10000 réunion
enregistrée le compteur grimpe
la bataille des chiffres continue aussi
oui parce que selon l'opposition et bien
ces chiffres sont truquées car un
citoyen peut contribuer plusieurs fois
sur le site et puis il ya aussi le
risque sur la plateforme que la
plateforme soit parasité par des
activistes politiques etc et de quoi
parle-t-on le plus quels sont les thèmes
qui s'impose dans ce grand débat
national
elle rompt parle toujours autant de
fiscalité à près de 30% l'écologie vient
ensuite
et là encore cette répartition n'est pas
fiable selon l'opposition car les autres
sujets discutés lors de débats ne sont
pas pris en compte et c'est le caméra
notamment lors de notre débat à
marseille discrimination fracture
sociale islamophobie tout ça est bien
tout ça ne rentre pas dans notre cas
d'un des quatre thèmes alors chaque
semaine vous épluchez pour nous
l'actualité de ce grand débat national
vous regardez tout ce qui se passe dans
les réunions publiques citoyenne ce qui
a retenu votre attention cette semaine
c'est la manière avec laquelle le
gouvernement a commencé à préparer les
esprits sur la réponse politique à
l'issue du grand débat c'est le plus de
la semaine
je ne sais pas ce que deviendra ce que
deviendront toutes les informations qui
sont consignés là j'espère qu'elles
seront utilisées
si jamais ce n'est pas le cas je pense
que la colère populaire sera d'autant
plus grande prudence monsieur macro
voilà il s'agissait préparer les esprits
vous l'avez dit tout doucement préparer
l'après débat vous à vous entendez cette
mise en garde une participante c'était
lors des deuils l'un des tout premiers
débats que nous avons suivis dans leurs
oeufs et c'est aussi ce à quoi s'est
attelée toute la semaine le gouvernement
l'espoir suscité est immense il faut le
dire et donc le risque bien entendu le
risque politique c'est de décevoir le
premier ministre l a reconnu voyait ce
qu'il a dit cette semaine c'était lors
de la réunion de groupe en marche
à l'assemblée le risque déceptif est
très important at il dit il faut
préparer nos concitoyens ce que les
propositions à la sortie ne seront pas
les réponses à toutes les remontées des
débats et même idée aussi du côté de
brune poirson on n'a pas de baguette
magique dit elle vous voyez les esprits
sont en train d'être préparée petit à
petit voilà et vous l'avez vu un c le
compte twitter de philippe mathon qui
est rédacteur en chef adjoint ici à lcp
qui avait cette info ce verbatim comme
on dit du premier ministre en exclu pour
elle ces belles on va terminer avec
l'oeil de la semaine que faire de toutes
les contributions écrites les courriers
envoyés par les citoyens et surtout les
cahiers de doléances en mairie une
société prestataire de la bibliothèque
nationale de france est chargé de
numériser cette montagne de papier et
louise grégoire accompagné d'elsa monde
un gars va on visité le siège de cette
société à chambray-lès-tours regarder
[Musique]
il n'y a pas eu que les contributions en
ligne il ya aussi les cahiers de
doléances et contributions écrit par les
citoyens vous voyez derrière moi il ya
plus de cinq cent mille pages à
numériser et c'est le défi de l'un des
prestataires de la bibliothèque
nationale de france
les numériser en quatre semaines venez
avec moi je vais vous expliquer
concrètement depuis le 25 février nous
recevons les cahiers citoyens en
provenance des préfectures
ces cahiers sont des photocopies nous
ont été transmises par la poste ou par
transporteur à partir de ces documents
que nous avons trié nous par préfecture
et par date de réception
nous allons préparer des lots de
production on se dirige sur la pièce
suivante dans laquelle nous avons un
scanner industriel qui va numériser à
150 pages par minute
la pièce se retrouve juste ici
alors cinq cent mille pages en quatre
semaines c'est un défi pour vous c'est
400 mille cinq cent mille pages regarder
ça défile à plus de 5000 pages par heure
ici donc on est on est tranquille sur la
d méthanisation
en revanche il faut que nous ayons toute
la matière il faut donc les départements
et tous remontés qu'est ce que la bns va
faire après de toutes ces informations
tout ce qui est numérisé ici a plusieurs
vocations à la fois alimenter les
transcripteur qui eux vont passer du
manuscrit à un texte word à la fois
alimenter les sociétés qui est au tour
de rôle envergure commence à analyser à
faire des synthèses et aussi un
archivage pérenne que nous faisons c'est
la bibliothèque nationale de france
avant de verser le tout aux archers
nationale mais là ça fait débat c'est
fini pour aujourd'hui vous repartez sur
les routes alice limoges à intéresse on
parlera éducation lors de notre prochain
ça fait débat
merci à vous merci à toutes les équipes
pour cette nouvelle semaine de ça vous
regarde la régie la rédaction germain
andrieu soizic bonvarlet netia pas cris
et sylvain poulet le programmateur de
cette quotidienne très bon week-end à
tous sur lcp
[Musique]
n'ayons pas peur des mots présentée par
valérie brochard dans un aux stands